hi everyone and welcome to some
subscriber Saturday chess and well I'm
your host today I am over here at chess
calm and and I'm gonna be playing you
guys mainly at 5-minute chess so do get
into chess calm do challenge me and I'm
gonna challenge you as well so yes so it
should should all be should be a good
little Saturday so I'll keep an eye on
the chat so I see over in a chat we
already have court Chester hello caught
Chester and we have Tiger trap hello
Tiger trap and a couple of you are here
already Jas is asking are you ready to
loose I think you mean lose I guess you
don't mean loose and I hope you mean
lose but no I'm not ready to lose I'm
gonna win every game today every single
and game so um anyway so it should be a
bit of fun so I'm just gonna change my
settings so I can take you guys on and
remember the way this works is that's
you and I'm gonna change my settings
don't worry about this and just so I can
face you guys and the way this works is
in order to play me you have to be a
subscriber on the chess calm twitch
channel so do you make sure you are a
subscriber it's quite a cheap thing to
do and that means you can play against
me today and other great grandmasters in
the future so there's a lot of benefits
really of them of you know become a
subscriber you get some funky emotes as
well is this a simul Bishop takes is
asking no it's a subscriber thing
meaning that you have to be a subscriber
and I'm gonna play against you guys
blitz chess and we'll just have some fun
I'm gonna crush you all I'm gonna crush
you all right that's what we're gonna do
and we see we have we have my cat
Charlie if you're wondering what this
chair is next to me well we have you
know that's the Charlie
yeah and he likes looking at the fish we
got the fish going about behind me so
all call them right so how do you
subscribe
I've been asked it's very easy to do I
think there's you can see the I think
it's above the video bar there's a blue
thing where you're watching this it says
subscribe that's on the desktop anyway
and or as it's how do I pronounce that
name you don't make it easy and you just
press exclamation mark subscribe so that
that's that that's another that's
another way of doing it
are they real fish well let me just see
if I can touch them they're in my
massive I actually have this massive
fish cage behind me you can see how big
it is look I'm very lucky it's a bit
like a James Bond lair I have like you
know I have like a hundred foot fish
tank behind me and you know these are my
fish and obviously Charlie's there any
likes trying to get the fish at some
point now if you believe that you
believe anything and you can probably
tell the fish are actually going in the
same motion all the time so don't don't
believe that we're not we're not gonna
don't don't don't believe that don't
believe that I'm right
so hello to everyone else who's joining
in Helms Knights a norwegian subscriber
you should all go and check out so and
let's start the game let's start so I'm
gonna be playing against well I'm gonna
call you blob I'm gonna call you the
blob man so we're gonna basically the
time limit with generally playing is
straight up five minutes so we're gonna
be doing that hello Charlie can you see
the fish you looking at the fish are you
yes you're looking at the fish and I'd
love to have a massive fish tank that
would be great behind me like a product
proper James Bond villain but it's not
so easy to do weight gain now Charlie
okay you're coming up here alright you
want to get nearer to fish so we start
the first game with a normal Queens
gambit and very nice I've got a cat bump
in my face hello Charlie hello thank you
for putting your cat bomb in my face and
we're gonna go for
a normal sort of variation where I'm
gonna try to come through the center and
well I don't know the FIRREA this one
it'd be nice I will start whenever I do
my Odin streams I always start with a
loss so it would be fantastic to not
start of a loss today I mean that that'd
be that'd be lovely so I'm just going to
develop quickly it seems like a good
idea and five minutes is a good time
limit because we get a chance to have a
little bit I can discuss the ideas a
little bit more any one thing I'm gonna
lose the game today will I lose the game
today
who knows and remember you can play me
if you're logged in to chess calm and
you're a subscriber on the site so well
bye charlie I'll see you later Charlie
you you you not you don't be on the
Canberra anymore okay so we get rid of
the Charlie cam so this position is
quite quite complex already my opponent
now threatening to take here and and
what ideas do I have well Queen d2 and
castles Queen side looks very
interesting so I think well I think
we're trying to start off today with
some interesting attacking chess I'll
get rid of the Charlie cam now as
Charlie has gone and my opponents not
getting involved my opponent is just
simply developing makes a lot of sense
and now I can even consider going d6 I
think I will play that now I mean that
the downside of that is I don't have
ideas of getting a checkmate on d8
anymore but my pawns my pawns are very
annoying for my opponent there now just
wondering he can't take care Queen takes
rook take Queen takes b2 which may
Charlie's my cat Charlie Charlie's gone
gone they also which is which is an idea
he might want to do because then I will
come to Queen Queen d8 check mates and
to do it why does Charlie they can't
have a camera why does the Pope have a
balcony you know you know answer that
question answer that question I don't
know because he's famous he wants his
own he wants his own camera
that's why simple okay so Bishop here
now I'd like to play Knight here but my
opponent will take that one maybe I can
still do that
other things I can try I'd love to get
this pawn rocking and rolling up the
board
something like d7 so that's another good
idea this overlooks a knight here Bishop
takes c3 pawn takes here and then Queen
b5 so I think he's okay he's surviving
now if he takes here do I even want to
open up the fr would that give me some
attack maybe later on I don't think so
so what I am gonna do well I'll count
I've got a castle anyway because now if
he takes here I don't think I can play
d7 because he goes Bishop takes d7 and
this Bishop will be pinning my queen but
it's certainly an idea so he's just
playing senseful he just wants to stop
me ever playing that move and now I'm
gonna play e5 just to try to get my
pieces into some more aggressive squares
so yeah this sub Saturday I mean I know
it's something that just come due on a
lot of Saturdays so it gives you guys a
chance to play against you know a title
play it's so like so I am a grandmaster
even though some people might you know
question that but I have I am a
grandmaster so you get shots playground
monster and you get a chance to you know
take down a grand monster in it in a
game so which I'm gonna try to win every
game today I'm gonna be brutal
well what I think we think so I'm doing
a three hour show and I think what I'll
do later on in the last hour or so would
take some would take some weird
challenges so when I say weird
challenges you know like you tell me
like if you want me to move pawns for
the first ten moves I'll try to win and
move pawns for the first ten moves now
in order to play me you have to be a
subscriber I'm being told who to
challenge and you have to challenge me
and then I'll decide who I play so there
we go
okay so see if I've been played now I
wish I had a plan
but I don't really don't really have
planned it now it's probably based
challenge me many games over so what is
my plan here people what am I trying to
do here sure I have a plan I'm palm down
do I try to get this night in does that
help me well then Bishop well then I go
d7 does this help me at all I don't see
how that helps me what else do I do
do I just go Bishop e2 doesn't like
great square do I even go g4 g5 well
that looks like fun so let's do that
let's do that that that looks like fun
let's go g4 g5 just try to open him up a
little bit and he can't go to Bishop
here yet cos what it can do but in d7 is
is a little bit annoying and I can
always go Eve for to block his Bishop
out so I think I've got quite I think
I've got a bit of compensation for the
pawn because this guy is it's like that
is like having and not stuck in your
throat isn't it having a pawn on that
Square it's a really really nice port
okay so he's gonna play this move next I
think I'll continue with my plan I'll
play here that oh there's a good plan
but it's something I mean I'll just try
to make him decide what what he wants to
do with this port because then my knight
might better might get a rock in Helms
Knight is saying she likes g4 thank you
Helms nights so I say go and check out
Helms light I know he's a streamer who
streams bughouse mainly Helms Knight is
that right you'll have to excuse me if I
if I'm wrong I think I've seen some of
your bughouse streams before so I'm
gonna try to get my rookie in now guys
they're very entertaining so go and
check out Helms night and now my night
is gonna come diving in quite
appropriate with a fish behind and I'm
obviously frightening a knight f7 we're
both getting a bit short a time now and
also I might just better get my porn
back so it seems to me that night f7 is
a pretty strong move here in we go in we
go always found a way out cry
d you crafty so and so of course I saw
that move okay so we just go Bishop GT
and don't I want to take that I don't
think I really want to take that pawn
because my knight looks quite stupid
over there so I'm actually just going to
move my knight back keep it in the
center of the board I think is the best
way to go and and how do we get
something or rockin and rollin over
there okay so my opponents playing well
now I think I will take that bishop off
because then this bishop on f3 should
always be quite strong and let's see if
I can try and get a rook eventually to
the back rank let's give that one a go
so okay so I'm gonna have to eliminate
that another right there is I can go for
a six so I will I'll give that a go but
I'd love to get a look on the back rank
that that or a queen or something so I'm
gonna try and now come in thank you to
the back rank and so in we come in we
come what sure what's your PL team or
suppose the PLT my football team Jimmy
Jimmy football team what what's my
football team pro league team I don't
know I mean I I did play for London
Lions Premier League oh okay
I'm bit slow today obviously my
opponents get very short time here so
okay Cheers glass of water it's not that
exciting but still I'll choose you um my
Premier League team is so I'm trying to
think as well okay I'll come back again
because I can take this one is well I
don't actually follow much football
funnily enough but and I do like I do
like Liverpool and I've always sort of
you know if I was gonna pick a football
team it would be Liverpool I don't I
don't know why
Liverpool because I live a long way from
Liverpool but when I was a kid I
to enjoy watching Liverpool play you
know there though you know they're very
good in rush was was their great play
rush rush rush rush so okay so thank you
for the game there globe and we're now
going to take in another challenge so
who's next okay
so hello to everyone the chat cruzi
leave hello mate
good to see you in the chat so I'm gonna
now play one nug me well how do we get
the challenges up then so how do we get
them okay so one knock me you are next
so thank you for the game the last one
like am I gonna get white in every game
that would be pretty damn cool yeah
cruzi League it was it was an
interesting night last hi I hope you've
got how did you get back home
by the way crew zealey that was what was
one thing I was wondering today I have
to say I've been a little bit tired
today but I had a nice restful day of
let day off work today while this is
kind of a bit of work but it's alright
okay so what I'm going to do here well
against the French defense one line I
often like playing is 'if I've and this
is the wing gambit I'm a very aggressive
player I like sacrificing I like getting
the initiative attacking all these kind
of things and the idea of this opening
is to try to get a porn chain like this
so I get d4 and see free and my opponent
did not capture the porn he probably
should have done because now we're gonna
get the same position but he hasn't
actually got an extra porn so he
probably should have taken there and the
reason I sort of tried do that is divert
his pawns away from the center I bet it
was quite expensive Lee I bet it was how
much your taxi home cost quite glad I I
had a nice easy walk home last night
hello - a VAD by the way in the chat
hello - morph have i Morpho your dinner
right chess patsy Utah Johnny Utah that
used to be Point Break
I used to be my favor I love that film I
love that film Point Break
that's glamour our eyes armed-robbery a
bit but I know is a filth but yeah it's
a great film great great great film that
was so yeah how much would your taxi Lee
last I are I'm intrigued so if you're
wondering what was going on Lee here a
friend of mine Kane came down and we had
a with another friend and a couple of us
had some food and a drink after work
last night 60 or 70 pounds okay it could
be worse could be worse okay so I'm
hoping he'll Castle so what am I going
to do if he cancels here come on guys
what am I going to play if he castles
what is gonna happen I remember in order
to play me you have to be ass up on
chess calms everyone subscribe subscribe
up people okay so what I'm gonna do well
I was gonna go I was gonna go for the
Greek gift now what I'm gonna do now is
try to stop him castling cuz I don't
like it when my panic castle so how do
we do that we go Bishop to a free and
look a lap that is a spanking diagonal
Oh cutting across him sixty pounds for
taxi that was quite it was quite
expensive taxi Lou yeah very expensive
taxi john said something like 110 pound
bill got 110 pounds for a taxi should
have got a last train home okay so I've
got my opponent's king stuck in the
center now when you're in such a
situation is this you should either be
looking at ways to open up the position
because then I can try to get an attack
against the king so maybe something like
taking and ecigs is an idea one nug me
is saying I'm not fast enough
well that might not be true but I do
love if that's your picture I do love
your beard so that makes up for it one
lovely it makes up for it so we're you
know so that's one idea so in order to
prepare that idea I'm gonna get a rook
here so I may be able to take and go a
six and just try to pull
blast blast through the middle ginger GM
drinking water is not fair well I do
have a glass of wine here in a beer
glass which is a bit peculiar a little
bit peculiar a little bit peculiar okay
so remember if you want to play get your
challenges in and um that's okay so
right okay so my opponents now put the
night here now I don't want to lose this
Bishop this Bishop to me seems like a
fantastic piece and so I don't really
want to play this next move but that
night is very strong so I'm just I ain't
gonna take it off and I have two ideas
here
either to try to get my knight in to d6
there's a pretty good idea maybe I can
come this way or this way or to play d5
because remember when you're playing as
King is stuck in the middle you want to
open it up but I think I think I like it
when all my pieces are harmonizing and
your idea of just taking the porn back
here can't be bad so we're gonna we're
gonna go for this one and my opponents
defended against that idea he's playing
well my pony's playing well now g4 might
be possible but I'm thinking my opponent
will put the knight on that square but I
think I might do that because I want to
come here with my knight and I at the
moment my opponents Knight is defending
that square so if I can get rid of that
night then d6 becomes a very attractive
square for my knight Triss is saying
Tris Kelton Kelly 10 maybe I saw if I
pronounced that wrong ah that's a good
move I some links and I was gonna castle
I think well that's happen you know I
had a castle there you Castle against me
okay that's annoying he's managed to
castle if he castles he's probably doing
okay because I've lost one of my best
attacking P so I've lost my bishop okay
well he should have definitely castled
there because now I've got this checking
can't castle 20 quid chips well I have
to say the English fish-and-chip
are very good it's probably like on
national dish fish and chips isn't it so
I reckon it's kind of like you know fish
and chips this it's very English but
there's a lot of money for fish and
chips okay so now we are going to come
for FSM so I'm being told Kevin bought
he was hosting I wasn't paid for his g4
but if that if you see me play chess
before you will know I'm a little bit of
a lunatic meaning I like attacking I can
move I'm gonna move the chair into the
swimming pool now look at that nice
I don't know that backdrop if he gets
annoying tell me because there's a lot
of fish going on there everything's a
suburb of London Guildford is quite a
way away from London but I say 30 miles
isn't it something like that I mean I'll
be honest um London is a fantastic place
but and there's big but if no I'm gonna
take here I'm just trying which night if
you come into England I would recommend
many other places apart from London I
mean I don't like it's a bit too busy
I'll go there sometimes but I prefer
like oh did I just Oh Oh careful careful
Simon I wasn't you thinking who's gonna
move this Queen there whoa
oh that's a bit nasty in there okay
let's not let's not get mated that
would be embarrassing so whoa don't take
the rook you get checkmated so I don't
know I mean uh-oh
so he's coming out oh dear oh my if I
sort of screwed this up a little bit why
did I take with that night that was that
was a disgusting move okay I think it's
still all right I take here I got Knight
g6 but and for example I like Brighton
down by there down by the sea there's a
lovely place I was at University down
there fantastic place I mean as loads of
cool shops see shut the seaside good
fish and chips
comedy clubs theatres pubs everywhere I
think it's got Brighton has got
something like 500 pups can you believe
it 500 pups in one place I mean you know
I know some people have tried to do how
to have a drink in every single pub when
I was at university it was like the
Brighton and challenge and the Brighton
challenge was to you know try try and
trying in the course of one year trying
to go to every single pub in Brighton
but yeah Bryson's a really cool place
and so if you ever do go to England I
really like place like Glastonbury
Scotland is beautiful there's some
lovely places that obviously is not
England but you know okay well I think
my opponent is some some serious dude ah
here does London her London has okay
thank you for the game one hug me
unlucky there you have me a little bit
scared when you got your queen in 2d
five that got me a little bit little bit
trembling there so next up we have and
I'm being told I'm he told who to take
on a boat Aires is a good player I'm
sure referring to Alexander botas she's
a good player a very good player she
playing over in Reykjavik at the moment
I believe in Iceland okay we're gonna
try doing openings in in most games I
think I'm gonna go for a bit of a perp
and Reykjavik one of my favorite
tournaments I've just had too much work
on to go down but Iceland this Iceland
is a fantastic country to go to it's one
of the most magical countries in the
world it really is so I wonder if he's
gonna go each for 85 unless have a look
so I'm just gonna castle and we're see
is he gonna lob oh he's going for Gary
you are oh I'm playing a caveman this is
the kind of player I love playing a
player off my own heart a lunatic okay
so when someone attacks on the wing you
want to attack in the center so I'm even
thinking e5 or c5 here
I'm going to go Eve I've because I'm
castle my opponents not like I said
before I want to open up the position I
open up the position yeah well it's it's
okay my idea here is to take here
because now I'm gonna try to get through
to his King yeah thanks to the game one
mug me it's a bit of a transition isn't
it track transitioning from like rapid
to blitz I mean five minute five minutes
like a life time for people like Hikaru
but you know it's it's this is them it's
quite quick
anyway Cheers I'm gonna have a little
bit of my wine up as there's a Saturday
evening does chat in my channel show up
here says esta la now I have absolutely
not the foggiest
meaning foggiest idea BAM desi is saying
play fine gold I'm gonna get I'm gonna
get enough of fine gold soon no I don't
you know no particular rush to play him
at the moment there's you know in under
two weeks time I'm taking on fine gold
so I don't give away on my opening
secrets although I've done any work at
all yeah but you guys this is you know
we're playing sup so all you have to be
as a subscriber on chest cough and you
have to be logged into chest comm
challenge me and I'll try to I'm trying
to try play as many people as I can so
it's not easy to play against the grand
masti I mean where did you find the
ground most of the place so hopefully
this is a good opportunity for some of
you to where to get interesting game of
chess okay so what are we gonna do here
so my PO now I like his spirit is very
aggressive I'm gonna line my pieces up
against his King because checkmate ends
the game hello Haunted's sink another
streamer until I I think
haunted sink very underrated stream I
love is set up there very trippy and am
I gonna fight those fish
you gonna fight those fish well I do
like my fish and chips but fighting
fishes is is probably all that I've
never fought a fish before so is it a
good time to start now
it's Saturday I like animals I don't
wanna go fight in any fish shop while I
set out I do like eating them
you know I was actually you know I thing
is I wanted to be vegetarian but I've
always been a meat-eater and you know I
did love animals and if it wasn't for
sausages I think I could be a vegetarian
but I just love sausages maybe I want to
try a bit harder in the future
I do love fish as well she like I
haven't already going off the tangent
and talking about sausages I love ya I
love my steak as well but Dave I do love
my food okay right so what are we gonna
be here
what does two options what was a couple
of options here I can take here we check
I can take care with the porn because
then my bishop can come here quite like
the look at that or I could just take
the bishop back so what am I gonna do I
think actually I might take with a pawn
oh he might move his Queen here and do
some nasty Knight chick I don't want him
to do that okay we give him a check
so we go we go for the check I like bugs
as well yeah I just oh god did I just
miss that one I was thinking about
sausages all my words
Simon you idiot you're thinking about
sausages too much no there you go I've
missed he could just come back what an
idiot I could have just that was
unbelievable okay so now now
unbelievable I could do that okay but I
still have a bit of pressure so it might
be okay still by me I could have had the
same position with an extra piece okay
let's let's go here
and try to win this night now I have a
check here then he moves his knight back
I have a lot of pressure in this
position so I feel it might be right I
can also maybe just move my bishop
around like this that is a very good
diagonal so let's go for that one get a
bishop in the game sausage or have you
seen been streams I don't think
vegetarians and vegetarians Ben's a
vegetarian which shocked me when I heard
but yeah I do oh do admire vegetarians I
have to say I do a mind okay right so
I'm in I'm in danger of losing this game
so I still have a lot of pressure but I
need to I don't want to lose this early
and where do I put my rook here or
didn't move let's move the bishop of
course this is why I got the bishop
around so let's do it and my bishops are
fantastic here aren't they I got very
good bishops and I might be winning a
piece back now okay what he's attacking
now and I said give me so can I go route
b4 with the idea of all my pieces of
working so this position is probably
okay a rip is saying Simon are you rich
from streaming I didn't see that move as
well god I'm missing a lot of moves
today am i rich from streaming no I mean
you don't really make any money from
streaming that's the thing I mean some
people do but I'm I'm fluffing this up
man
okay some people do but I mean you only
make money really if someone donates we
got loads of subscribers and I I
personally don't have a lot of that I
mean I like I like streaming so is
something I enjoy doing
I like playing blitz and stuff say is
it's alright but I'm certainly not I'm
not a millionaire quite yet if that's
what you mean okay so my opponent is
defending well and I have how many pawns
I have three pawns
a bit of an attack his King is very weak
so it's probably alright but I have
played some pretty shocking news in this
game his Queen is a very good piece in
the middle of the board there how many
subs to become a millionaire it's a good
question er I mean I don't know I mean
he Carly is smashing it at the moment is
he
Hikaru he's really smashing it but I
mean he's a great player he deserves it
so okay let's let's try to let's try to
come round here then that looks like an
interesting way to go
I spent the chess bronze doing you doing
well I mean what happens is I mean I
explain as far as I know how it works
and okay I want to win this game so is
you do you get like every time someone
sobs you get about two dollars fifty a
month from them so if you have okay know
if you have like 100 subscribers you'll
get $250 a month which I guess is
something like I get you know something
around around that mark now what am I
doing here this is this is the question
so but if you obviously if you have
thousands you think you're starting to
get 2500 a month so it really does
depend okay on how many you get you get
the odd donation and stuff like that as
well so yeah okay you know it can be
good obviously
right well what's happening here then so
I am trying my best to make my opponents
life difficult and that's a very nice
diagonal I have this one coming in but
my opponent is defending well I'm a
little bit up in time oh look it out
he's trying to checkmate me down there
like I say he's playing very well now
can I come in with a check he's trying
to come down here now isn't he so check
and it gets at least a draw then how do
I stop the draw can't can I
ah maybe it's winning
oh no I've got mate core I saw that all
along obviously obviously that was my
plan obviously I had a great planet whoa
what I have to say good game there sir
a boaters that was a good game good game
I mean I must have had you out the
opening but blundering a piece like that
I mean luckily in my position was still
quite dangerous and I played the start
quite well but you play very well at the
end there so well done sir well done
that was sir that was a good game you
gave me a very good fight and you had me
on the rope so expect you were
definitely winning at some point passion
have blundered that wasn't it was an
interesting game okay um so who's next
so let's all look so we're gonna now
play f1 n1t why and remember in order to
play me you have to be subscriber
let's get big Rob guy and shall we lie
so I'm gonna try to play dim opening in
every game that's a good challenge this
is the grub and this is an opening for
serial killers and lunatics I was told
as in maybe the most famous person who
played the grub this is a little
question for you do not Wikipedia that's
cheating
the most famous person to play the grub
was the strongest ever player in America
he claimed apparently he had the highest
ever rating in America higher than Bobby
Fischer's rating so who am I talking
about and he played the drop he played
the drop in nearly every game he loved
playing the grop this crazy this crazy
move in the dance are well done Mary hat
man well I I thought you might know Mary
as as the Grob is your opening isn't it
this one is basically the grub is your
little baby isn't it I mean I've seen
your play some great games in the drop
and by the way thank you to everyone
who's joined in we have
raid the viewer ship seemed to go up by
like 1200 there so unless I'm seeing
things so hello to everyone who has just
come and joined in its subscriber its
subscribers Saturday so if you want to
play me you have to be a subscriber to
chess comm channel and we're playing
five minute chess you get chance to play
grandmasters to get yourselves on it's
Hikaru so Thank You Hikaru for a raid
very kind Hikaru cheers so we're just
said we were just well I say we it's
only me here so ice pretty should say me
I I was just saying how it seems to be
going forever well you're streaming
you're doing it very regular as well as
being us champion and this could stuff
keep it up so yes indeed Thank You
Hikaru for the rate so the post time
talked about personally used to play
this opening all the time and he had
higher a higher rating than Bobby
Fischer apparently was none other than a
player called Claude was it Claude was
blood what's his surname Bloods blood
month was that Claude blood man I know
it's Claude blood good that was it blood
good and Claude Blount good the reason
he had such a high rating and the reason
I say you know it's an opening third
murderer's is that he got his rating in
prison only playing sort of I think
postal games in prison and he like
nearly won every game and he he
basically I think he was in prison for
murdering his month I think he murders
his month so he had a bit of you had a
bit of a mummy issues by the sounds of
it you know well for murdering a month
colonizes it so but he played the the
Rob all the time and he did very well
okay let me just look just see a little
alert box I'm just gonna read that one
and so yeah and other people I know who
played this opening g4 this is an
English chess player by the name of
Michael batsman who was one of my well I
say I've never really had a coach as
such
but he helped me a lot Mike Baz when he
was around my area International Master
Botvinnik x world champion Botvinnik
said of mike batsman he said he was one
of the most talented players he's ever
seen and he started to play the Grob he
played one a six he played loads of
weird and wonderful stuff ok now I have
a very strong little tactic or line here
can anyone see the tactical line am i
endorsing murdering one's own mother to
improve your chest no that's that's not
that's not that my letting my next DVD
not my next DVD
okay so basment is a legend indeed he is
a legend so ok anyone see the tactic if
anyone see the tactic well the tactic
I'm thinking of is Queen be free check
and then rook h7 and then I come here
and that might well be the end of the
game did I have then I have some Bishop
here checkmate ideas as well this could
be very nice and now bang and the point
here is if King takes that is checkmate
and that is the move I and threatening
as well as rook h8 checkmate I don't
know how he's gonna stop checkmate and
that does not help him because I have
rocket shake should we should we do a
bit of showboating here oh he's not
gonna let me check mate him oh come on
Oh cowboy that's it that's that's no
ok so I think we're gonna do a bit
ban should we play another batsmen like
opening I think so
ok so next up I remember if you want to
play me you have to be a sub um so a
subscriber to the chess twitch channel
I'm looking at the chat on twitch.tv
slash chess I'm not looking elsewhere I
haven't got like 20 eyes especially what
I'm trying to play as well so I'm gonna
be looking at the chat there I'll try to
answer any questions you have as well
and and well so where we going who's
next ok so next up we have perpetual
stalemate interesting name
and remember you have this subscriber
I'm a subscriber now oh thank you kitty
kitty hisses I thought I wore it already
was a subscriber so that was a little
bit okay a little bit of a shock
hello perpetual stalemate whoo
I like this perpetual stalemates
comments how can you not like how can
you not like it when someone puts this
comment before they play a game that's
me ginger GM by the way good luck you
handsome Beast
why thank you why thank you my dear very
kind of you to say so okay now he's
playing the London system so what I'm
going to do against this is a little
this is my homemade line against the
London system so if you know your
opponent plays the London system look at
the way I play this and I don't think
there's any fear on it I like putting
the bishop here it's a nice piece that's
stage one so I'm gonna tell you what to
do against there and now I like putting
my nikon d700 d6 Knight d7 stage two
because it gives me opportunities to
play e5 and I don't block the bishop up
so let's do that Knight d7 and then can
you guess what stage free will beat will
stage free I like going h6 and g5 off we
go because this is with Bishop g7 coming
quite a nice way to get such a okay so
he's stopping me and I don't want him to
go h5 and clamp Gary the G port so I'm
gonna go g6 and if he goes h5 I'll go g5
the stock give a little kick back he
pushes Harry well you know cheeky so so
this is kind of like well that the setup
on going for has a name and I did want
g5 at the petrol you're right you're
right there sir
I wanted it okay so this is like the
setup and going for is really like a
hippo hippopotamus hippopotamus my dear
yes bonds huh yes Mr Bond I'm playing
the hippo the hippopotamus okay um
well thank you kitty kitty hisses for
the kind words
I do have a youtube channel I do also
stream on my ginger gem Channel I think
I'm streaming tomorrow I streamed with
my friend Blair yesterday it was a bit
mental and this is kind of the hippo to
starting position okay so now that my
opponent has committed his king I have a
target I know what I want to go for
because checkmate ends the game so I'm
going to start with a pawn storm to try
and open up lines but first of all let's
move my knight around because my knight
might have potential to dive in nearer
his King and the thing is my position is
very hard to break down you can see the
pawn structure thank you s e24
subscribing and that's very kind of you
describe to the the channel here right
so what do we do I'm thinking c5 but
that's a bit risky was rook lined up
against my queen I'm thinking bishop
here unless it's a little bit cheeky
that one isn't it you know trying to
trying to grab grab that poor little
poor little guy over there what else can
I do
can I can I go b4 how about that let's
try that one that's the most interesting
sacking a pawn and if he takes I might
even go a 5 because I just want to get
some lines towards his King so a5 this
check bishop c6 let's go a5 I could have
gone Knight here first so he's trying to
keep it closed and now can I get this
Knight around or cannot or should I just
push so this is a good movie she's
keeping it closed over here and so
what's my plan a pile of dude ah if you
get if you get my drift if you get my
drift
well c6 is appealing to me because again
I'm trying to open up lines but it's
quite a risky way of playing this to me
I'm actually I'm at I'm like a minute
down on the clock as well whoa I could
have gone a 4 but then he goes a 3 and
he saw blocks my pawn up over there
so I want a real okay now now let's
let's what do I just move the Queen here
let's do this one because I don't really
want to give him a check I mean this one
maybe I'll take with my knight or maybe
with a bishop if I take with my knight
when he takes on c6 can you go Queen
here and that's this is a little
annoying annoying move that it's
annoying move I don't like you no
annoying news where I can go Knight d5
then I've got Bishop a6 so I mean it's
okay to sack pawns when you I mean when
you're castle when you're on opposite
sides of the board probably at some
point I will Castle kingside probably
okay so he's okay so there now I've got
a lovely square on this one so I'm gonna
put my knight on that square because you
can't go a free anymore to kick it away
so it's alright to sack pawns when
you're on opposite sides because it's
all about who gets the attacking first
and you know it supporters don't matter
because if you checkmate your opponent
well if it doesn't matter who's got an
extra pawn or racial queen or whatever
does it it really doesn't matter see so
we're gonna try and checkmate him and
now my knight has got a very good square
near his King and I will open him up by
taking here but I don't want him to go
Queen takes and swap Queens so I think I
will now die Castle to think about
canceling I give him a target to attack
so do we have another raid coming in
someone said a raid okay maybe not
maybe there was no okay so I'm get a car
so anyway because I want to take care
and I want to keep the Queen's on the
board so I don't want him to swap off
the Queen's okay well thank you for the
raid hello Ben my good friend and are
you looking forward to are you looking
forward to our match Ben are you looking
forward to it that is that is a question
are you looking forward to some
interesting chess well
well whatever whatever happens me and
Ben will certainly it'll be fun
fun fun for one of us probably painful
for the other okay so what is happening
now so he wants to put his knight on
this square that I can see now do I have
Queen here rook here or am I just gonna
lose on time these are the eternal
questions of life okay what about this
give them a little a little little
cheeky check over there is that is that
legal
is that gonna work yeah well Williams
versus Feingold is happening and it's
happening in under two weeks eleven days
it's happening not next Friday but a
Friday after so we are rockin and rollin
with that one rockin and rollin it's
happening I'm supposed to say it's a bit
of fun
only after losing well it's not really
fun if you lose let's be honest I mean
you know we don't play chess to lose do
we know that B Nobi a bit depressing you
know
I mean I'm competitive how am I going to
handle the talk the talking um it's a
very good question I didn't handle it
very well last time but luckily this
time we're streaming from from our own
our own streams so we're doing it like
you know I'm streaming from my channel
Ben from his so I won't be able to hear
Ben in my ear and let's like log into
his stream which I think is I think is
going to be very unlikely as I'm gonna
try to concentrate so luckily I won't be
here in Ben you know okay right now do I
have night C free chick takes Knight d5
chick that looks like so much fun but it
also might be a pile of poo let's just
go a free I don't know I don't know if
night C free check was working porn
takes are then some discovered check
there it could well have been working
like maybe even night to this square but
and this way I get here coming in I get
pressure here I've got a to this this
looks very very strong very very strong
so Cheers anyway Cheers so this this
this is we're coming through we're
coming through so what's perpetual
stalemate saying so I've seen you
playing this before you wanted g5 you
have to mute them to keep it fair here
in the same five jokes of three hours is
torture well you know who am i to
disagree of you sir
Who am I I think that's okay right so
there's a number of ways I can open up
my opponents position something like
night a two is very interesting does
that work or should we just go let's go
let's keep it simple this one this one
and then my queen will try to come in my
opponent very shorter time this is only
one check isn't it so let's let's come
in here this is a big check I'm
threatening on a two or a one so my
attack has come through so it seems like
this is quite good attack and remember
if you want to play this should be mate
now night here's always that that's a
very nice mate look at that one bang and
that is check mate it's not just a check
that was a double check mate there thank
you for the game perpetual stalemate you
were a gentleman and very kind of you to
plate so cheers remember a shout out cop
off gambit thank you for the cheer out
it goes to chest calm so oh ho yeah
thanks to the game to petrol stalemate
very very kind of you so we got a clean
record so far a hundred percent can I
keep it up for the whole three hours
come on guys come on give me a challenge
give me a challenge give me a challenge
will you all give me challenges you're
putting up some very good very good
fights so remember in order to play me
and if you want to get chance play a
grandmaster if you think you can take
down the big ginge that's my nickname oh
I think I just made out
then come and come and play me and
challenge you have to be a subscriber to
the chess calm twitch channel and you
have to be logged into chess and then
there's a queue I'm gonna try to get
through I'm gonna try to play as many of
you as I can so next up is chess gal
15:11 so hello to chess Cal and chess
Cal is from Poland so I'm going to play
I was talking about Michel basment
openings and another favorite opening of
Michel basment it might look like I'm
about to play the French defense here
but Michel Boozman and also Tony miles
and sometimes even I think Spassky
played this move a six have you seen
this move before it's a crazy idea you
want to play b5 and Bishop B sir so for
example b5 and I try to get the bishop
here and later on you try to get your
Knight to d5 so you go Knight f6 and
then get your knight there and it's very
interesting web play so this is another
idea of one of the most imaginative
chess players in the world international
master Michael Baz Luhrmann of England
okay so my opponent is going here to try
to block out my bishop and I think it's
natural for me now to develop a piece
and to put some pressure on those two
ports so we're gonna we're going to play
that one
I saw someone they donate 10 ke bits one
night to a streamer how much is how much
does that then how much is a how much is
how much is that ten ten thousand how
much is that I don't even know how much
that is is that like a lot of money I
don't know I don't know what bits are
really bits are is that not $100 $100
eight quid 80 quid $10 I don't know I
don't know what these bits are 100 is it
$100 okay I think the most I saw I think
I saw a Fiona my good friend Fiona and
she got did she get a donation of I
think she got like 500 quid or safe was
quite cool I've been I'm also been told
by haunted sink that's I'm crossing
brands someone else is already there's
already taken the name big ginger so I
can't actually take the name big ginger
so I better stick to - ginger GF okay so
my point is playing well here I'm a
little bit concerned because my light
squares around my king are quite weak
that was a very good move now I do get
my night to this square and that's one
of the reasons you put your pawn on b5
you kind of stop white playing c4 but
I'm a little bit worried I'm a little
bit worried that I might get some damage
coming towards me with these guys coming
in so I'm not entirely happy about it
not entirely happy to know I was
applying that you used it on a dirty
streaming sites oh okay well oh well
thanks to that horn to sing you you
obviously know me far too well that's so
you know if we're supposed to be keeping
these things harsh harsh okay so my
opponent has gone c4 and I'm gonna take
that one I believe so
now he's ready to take this they do I do
i flick in a chick doesn't help me
Bishop d2 I've got the bishop coming
here as well so I think I think I'll
just continue calmly developing and I'll
keep my bishop for now and I'm thinking
if I can get canceled my rook could be
very good on the fr so word is asking
why am I not commentating a trake of it
I don't think I had much of a budget
this this year round words 20 I think
the Icelandic Chess Federation cost
quite a lot money to to host commentary
and tournaments and I think they just
didn't have much much of budget
basically so they couldn't afford
obviously I don't commentate for free I
need to get my accommodation paid for
some money is it's my job so so that's
that's why oh look at that cheer is that
a thousand whoa d1m you're trying to buy
your way into playing a game that was a
very nice cheer thanks math there we go
we have a chair stop making stupid walk
well you're gonna have to guess people
I to be honest thought I simply was like
running out of clothes today I don't put
much of a wash on so by lightest t-shirt
stop making stupid people famous chess
is a good way to try and do that Hortis
sink is saint ginger GM do you get the
donations here or should I go to your
channel I don't I don't actually receive
anyone who donates here and well I won't
I won't get into that money that's chess
coms money so I don't actually receive
hear that but it's nice to support chess
in general I mean you can I mean it you
know it's very nice to get donation me I
mean that's very kind thing to say and I
mean when I'm streaming on my channel if
you could you know if you want to help
me out and donate a couple of quid you
know I be I'll be very grateful you know
it does it does make a big difference
grandmasters are not the richest it's
not the richest Korean well but yeah
just you can if you want to well porn
crusher says only a set wine well the
good thing is I can I can em I can
actually buy wine with money as well
Paul brush pusher okay thank you another
cheer outs
pif the magic dragon I love that that
song it was it mary mark and mary
markers some well my god come on move it
puff the magic dragon hands maybe i
think i was quite controversial song was
there it was meant to have some
connotations should we say in the 60s
peter paul and mary that's the one i
like their songs it's shaolong or sang
shall on great song that won the greats
off good old folk music how do pro chess
players earn money interesting question
well by getting paid for doing various
things really and I mean I'm just gonna
start that one being taken coaching and
I I'm quite lucky because I make my own
DVDs my own company
you know tutorial dvds I'll be doing
I've like 10 years and they bring in a
little bit of cash not a great deal I do
Ches calm and I'm not just saying acts
on me I'm not gonna say this because I'm
just here but I actually mean it just
calm are the best the best guys I've
ever worked for in the chest well they
treat they treat you very well they give
you great support and and it's I've been
very lucky that they've decided to have
me work for them so I'm grateful to them
already have
I do DVDs chess space so I film for them
on pace like chess I could push and say
that you know Chet I sell my services
around the chess world let's just put it
that way I've written like eight to ten
chess books I used to teach chess in
schools sometimes get paid to play
competitions sometimes get paid when you
win competitions you know there's lots
of stuff lots of stuff okay you can do
but it's not easy you have to you have
to work hard it can be quite boring if
you're trying to play for prize money
it's very competitive very very
competitive by the davie days that is
one way doing it yeah that song gave
birth to the prodigy Simon's well you
know we'll be surprised okay right so I
kind of like my position here we've got
a lot of pressure coming down over here
I've moved my rook here because I was
thinking about doing a little swinger
swing swing in around oh it's soap such
a pity I can't go Queen H free don't be
a then sort of rookie for checkmate but
that's not working so I'm trying to look
for on trial it for a stylish finish
here this is often one of my sins rather
than playing - okay let's go here let's
do the swinger and go for h2 now if
Knights G free can we go rook takes here
Knight takes here rook takes G to check
King h1 and do the yo-yo do the yo-yo oh
oh Dulli yo-yo why my makeup random of
songs today I don't know I don't know
and well I could do but then my opponent
has some rook takes c6 in that line so
it maybe doesn't work so well so where
what else I'd be lovely if I could play
this I really want to make it work takes
give up my queen takes it King
here is there no way I can make that
possible rook takes F to check rook
takes c6 now I can't see how it's
working peeps people so instead I'll
probably have to move my queen so do I
have to come back here that's a little
bit disappointing good defensive idea
there good defensive idea for my
opponent to bring the knight around to
the square well kill it kill Ian hello
hello Killian hope your dinner right man
and my Irish friend was thinking the
same idea I just can't get it to work
Killian what's it working I don't know
maybe it was working so I don't know
well I don't really want to swap Queens
okay my time my parents times shorter so
I should be okay but this is such a
strong piece isn't it so well I say time
and I start thinking like freezing don't
freeze don't freeze Simon okay now I
wish I knew what is doing but I don't
I'm gonna okay you can have that port
I'm not I'm not too stressed out about
that one I'm trying to get Harry coming
down the board there we go thank you for
the game chess girl you played well day
you came up some good defensive ideas
moving your night around to e2 was a
very nice idea
very nice defensive idea so I just tell
you guys what I was thinking about when
chess girl moved her night to 8g free I
was thinking yeah I don't know if it
works or not it doesn't look like fun I
was thinking about taking here rook
takes G h2 and after here going rook
takes G to check forcing King here but
the problem is chess girl has her rook
lined up against my bishop so I wanted
to play rook takes F to do I try to do
the yo-yo check but now I was worried
about rook takes c6 these are the kind
of things I was trying to analyze and I
couldn't work this position out I
thought I might be a piece down at the
end of the complications I thought if I
take here
my opponent takes here
takes it and then takes even here and
after everything gets exchanged off I'm
a piece down and probably losing hence
why I didn't play but meh I was very
interesting very interesting game so I
just sort of won on time there which I
needed to win the time okay so remember
in order to play me a subscriber
Saturday you need to be a subscriber to
this channel the chess comm channel you
need to get over to chess calm and get
you know get into the arena and
challenge me and next up next up we have
John the big man Davis what that if he's
a big man it could be it could be really
tiny I mean also that mean height of
course so if you're thinking anything
else we'll leave why is that what are
you doing what are you waiting
okay so openings I've played this one I
played this one I played this one so I
think now we're gonna go for the
Sicilian let's do the Sicilian I played
the Sicilian for a while and my opponent
is playing night here so my favorite
Sicilian and this is the open Sicilian
you often get very exciting games night
here so my opponent hasn't got time
place C for my favorite Sicilian is the
dragon so we're gonna go for this one
this is a very double-edged position
because you can often and you will often
get checkmated down on the H far and
this is again one of Bobby Fischer's
favorite ideas was to just go h4 h5 now
this is all theory now the next move is
kind of a speciality move of mine and
again if you're gonna watch the stream
you know he probably gets a note away I
think and I think when you're constant
opposite sizes he who attacks first and
there's a lot of moves here rook c8 s--
the main move but I'd like going b5 this
is my specialist move I don't mind
giving up a pawn because my figuring is
it gives me another open file to attack
off you know if my plant takes that pawn
I can often go Queen b8 rook c8 and try
to get these lined up and this also
starts the pawn storm so I get these
guys run
up the board and thank you for the kind
comments quite in sync it's good to look
stream okay so now he's going a free so
when your opponent has castled on the
opposite side and you're attacking you
want to open up as I keep saying as many
lines as you can so I'm gonna go b4 I'm
gonna try to open up the area file re re
gay porn the airy open airy file so
we're gonna we're gonna go for this one
and we're gonna try and swing our Queen
over here and then go bang put that in
your pipe and smoke it dear boy as
someone would say okay so my opponent
now has moved the Knights of this one I
have a couple of options I can take this
one and go Knight c4 I then attack the
Queen attack the bishop seems very good
or I could just take there and open
things up so let's do that
that looks like a jolly good start and
we're now going to try to open up the B
file and this is kind of a typical
attacking idea typical attacking idea
remember there's quite a lot I don't
know if we just had another dumper
people over here but thank you everyone
who's come along to watch the street and
if you want to play you can play a
grandmaster allegedly that's what I am
and it always do that yes be subscribed
it's a twitch channel go on to chess
calm and rock and roll okay so now do I
take here and go Knight c4 or do I just
keep using is buried the b-pawn isn't it
bury the b-pawn little s maybe let's do
it okay let's let's just keep taking
porn Zoe look at that pool and that
pawns on a runner that is that's that's
like a it's like a grenade isn't it is
blowing up my opponents King position
that one blowing up the position opening
it up so we will take that and it looks
like my attack has landed first oh look
at this this could be absolute carnage
boom
boom and the idea of that move is of
course my opponent resigned because if
he takes it then Knight c4 is what we
called a very very big fork this is a
fork when you attack multiple things
with one move and here the night is
going bang bang bang so we call that a
family fork a family affair so thank you
for the game
umm that's basically yeah you've got a
bit of it you got a bit of trouble
you've got a little bit of trouble in
the opening there don't you sir
but I'm you know it's it does happen to
even the best of us
no no it's happened to me many times so
next up and remember if you want to play
come into chess comm make subscribe any
combo be a cheapskate it cost you
nothing Jen's chess is just subscribe
I'm not picking the players by the way
so I'm getting a list of players who are
subscribed and I'm gonna pick them up
who play and next up we have mint Joe
mint show so I'm on a hundred percent
for the first hour can I keep it up
so we've played the Grob d4
now what about a bit of birds this is
named the birds opening and this is
named after English player Henry
bird and I actually have a book written
by the guy my dad was a chess player was
given to him and actually has Henry
burrs own handwriting in the books is
probably worth a few Bob and I it's a
bit it's basically like a reverse Dutch
and I love the Dutch and I like putting
my bishop on this square in the birds if
I can cuz it's a nice little pin I'm
pinning that night down and we're just
gonna now now something like b6 would be
very normal because this bishop it gains
a healthy diagonal on b2 and it is a
tricky line as below the saying Bishop
to b5 and now I can retreat the bishop
but the other idea is just to take here
and at the right moment this is a very
nice square for my night which should be
able to recapture the bishop pair I mean
you hear a lot I mean well I hear a lot
of people talking about the bishop pair
you know he's got the bishop pair he
must be better and people go on about
the bishop pair now my honest opinion is
that's it's a bit overhyped the bishop
pair the bishop pair because I mean I
think unless you're like 2,600 strength
it doesn't really matter if you've got
the bishop pair or bishop or a knight I
mean I'm not right you know I think I
think no I prefer Knights
I actually prefer Knights persley
because I think Knights a tricky oh
they're tricky little guys they jump
about jump up jump up and get down the
tricky low guys you know I like the
noise okay so my opponent wants to go c4
I feel and he wants to try to get rid of
his double pawns this is my long-term
target and hence why he might put that
there so a normal move here is to put
the Bishop 185 because now if he plays
this I can take it and it attacks here
the rook so I gain again a little tempo
when I when I play that move now he's
gotten a rook to b7 and positionally I
think I'm a little bit better because
he's got this pawn these pawns can all
be weak
the ones I've highlighted so I'm
thinking do I try to play E for well
first of all I'm just gonna put my queen
here it gives me better control of this
square and better control of this square
so it's a handy connecting the rooks is
always a good idea this is when you get
everything out of the way so that rooks
can swing swing around so this all looks
good and my opponent has now going for
the exchange of bishops now if I go here
straight away my opponent might know if
he takes a tape with a knight yes okay
so we will go a four pushing in the
center a little bit and this is all very
logical moose and I've got a nice
position here nice small advantage ecigs
so how do we improve more well I'd love
to get my knight into this square
somehow but I can't see how to do that
instead I'm just gonna start attacking
his weak pawn so I'm gonna go Queen to
e3 and if my opponent plays d4 he
basically you know he limits his pawns
and he gives me the c-4 square for my
night so he doesn't positionally he
doesn't want to play that move that'd be
a pretty ugly move and now I think I'm
just gonna go g4 you know why not
this is push let's just push on and one
idea I'd love to get in is to get the
pawn here and get a knight to this
square so I'm wondering if I can ever do
that okay so my parents moved the Queen
over here and I think in this particular
scenario in exchange a queen as is fine
for me because again I've talked about
his porn weaknesses over on the Queen
side Simon have you ever considered to
be a parrot yeah a course I have that
that's just the kind of thing I
regularly think about being a parrots
yeah I mean you know doesn't everyone
I mean that's just normal normal fault
process isn't it you do get some odd
questions you look have I ever thought
about being a carrot you look well Frank
thank you for your contribution there
that that was very a you know very very
very interesting contribution okay right
now the reason I'm just put in a root
care is I'd want to make sure the only
way my opponent can improve his position
is by playing c4 then are they not now I
can just whip it off whip it off I think
how I fought about buying a parrot's um
no I haven't thought about buying a
parent to be honest I don't want someone
shouting things back at me you know I
don't want anyone repeating what I say
like you play my tent and all that I
don't you know
no I don't I don't know I've never
considered getting a parrot not not my
cup of tea old boy not not my not my
chips and gravy I'm more of a cat and
dog man you know give me a castle dog
any day of the week
parrots not for me sir not for me okay
so now let's get this night somewhere
better if he moves this pawn my knight
could get to one of these two squares
but he's not gonna do that he really
should be thinking about moving this
pawn and well let's just put the king
feels a bit safer on g2 for some reason
have I ever met the snooker player John
Parrott I love a lot of questions today
I haven't I mean I I am quite a big
snooker fan Sneaky's a fantastic game
but I've met Steve Davis interesting
Steve Davis I mean I met that chap he's
a chess player actually I met him a long
time ago in London okay so this is it my
opponent has played this move and that's
not being saying that is the one move I
didn't really want to allow him to play
but okay we can't always get what we
want okay so I'm gonna win this porn
anyway but it's not a it's not a great
porn I'm gonna win because I do double
my pawns but okay so it's still an extra
pawn my opponents Knight is pretty bad
because it can't move anywhere and I'm
relying on this move to shore up my
position and maybe I'll just go rook f2
just so I defend my second right - any
checks and hours should be should be a
bit better here
have I ever dreamt about a parrot this
is there's a bit of a bit of a parent
theme going on today have I ever dreamt
about a parrot that's a good question is
it a good question well it's a quite
it's question it's not about good
question no way ever dreamt about
parents um I dunno why I like that I
don't know why I like this parrot theme
for
no I don't know I can recall I don't I'm
not I'm not a massive dreamer I don't I
don't know I don't dream a lot is your
answer I guess whatever whatever that
means
okay so where's he trying to get his
night now this is one thing you should
always do and he's trying to maybe get
his night there but in the meantime let
me try to get my night here because if I
get my night here I have f6 and I might
be able to set up a checkmate scenario
and I also stopped his night coming to
c5 so it's an attacking and defensive
move so what I'm maybe trying to do here
is to get some checkmate position like
this coming in so let's see let's see if
I can set that set up a checkmate with
my rook now coming here and then
eventually coming round so okay so he's
going here if I go here he gives me a
little check so let's we have to be
careful when his knights on the board he
epic L remember I said I didn't like my
Knights can you see the idea I'm trying
to do now he's being annoying if I go
here he goes
Knight here and then check here then I
can go King F free does he have a good
check I don't think so so always check
so I meant go here first night here and
then rook h1 and then if he checks here
I can go King back and I'm hoping he's
gonna find it okay so now my checkmate
theme should be working this is a well
known checkmate pattern where you come
in and you come round like this and the
knight on f6 is very very strong so just
going for checkmate and I think the
eagle has landed the parrot has landed
and it has and we're gonna checkmate him
on one of these two squares either there
or here and that is Chuck mutt Chuck
mutt as they say in Germany shark Mart
stock Mart
shock Mart
okay so we okay so any more questions if
you like parrots
you have to be aware of pista kosis also
known as parrot fever we certainly have
a lot of parrots information coming our
way today by the way thank you I saw we
had another subscriber there to the
channel so thank you very much anyone
else is just subscribed and who's next
so we got next and I see now we haven't
we have a list so next up we have and on
undefeated as yet is say 20 so say 20 we
are in Jacky the Swede
when is Harry going into space we'll
talk about that in a second okay so
first of all I got to think what opening
I'm gonna play I'll try to play
different opening in every game and in
this game we're gonna go further
I'll give you clues and you have to
guess it any anyone anyone got that that
in anyone guess the opening Tigers
modern the lion you bright with what
kind of knowing what kind of mind that
black lying so that's all gonna go for
well done Mary hat man they're parrots
yeah I don't think there is an opening
called the parrot if there was i I'll be
playing it now for sure so we've trying
to make up a parrot opening so someone's
asking me would I be sending Harry into
spaces and some of you might be thinking
what on earth is is he going on about
has he finally lost the plot after all
those crazy years and what's the meaning
of that is is that I call my H born
Harry the H bull as you may or may not
know and I love throwing Harry down the
board and I had this really cool idea
and we're gonna try to do it but it fell
through last time I try to get it
working I wanted to send Harry D H porn
into space not on an Israeli spaceship
because I don't need to die but
if you saw that then Israeli spaceship
crash on earth - debt on not on earth on
the moon today was that right do you
weigh thank you for cheer death is that
right when I just make an app I think
that's right but I'm I was thinking
about attaching him to a weather balloon
which doesn't really go into space but
they can still go over a hundred
thousand feet high so you go in the
stratosphere then go bloody high you
know maybe not quite space but they can
go a long long way so I thought yeah
that's this I'm not you know just as
getting this is a cool idea so I looked
at this and I thought yeah let's do it
let's make a weather balloon and then
we're gonna make this weather balloon
we're gonna attach the very light thing
- I'm gonna have cameras in this like
the bottom the weather blew and I'd love
to take here we're gonna have cameras a
GPS unit because you need to the weather
balloon has to come back to earth and
you have to get the the camera footage
and record the whole whole whole thing
and I thought yeah this this is this is
this is cool yeah this is a cool idea I
think I will give up this point I don't
know every like I like Paul's anyway so
I wanted to and I was going to attach on
this light package that we send in space
Harry the H port so I was going to get a
little porn and I was gonna put him on
the weather balloon and record him dress
him up as mr. mad Harry and send him
into space record it and put the videos
up on YouTube I mean I think I think
that's a pretty cool idea I mean it's a
bonkers idea and I might you know maybe
I'm just you know maybe I should
probably see someone about these ideas
but it's an idea let's just put it that
way I mean I think that's a cool idea
what you reckon and so I don't know
maybe maybe this will one day occur
maybe I will I will get my dream at some
point so but yeah I know I have to
arrange it I did get contacted by a NASA
astronaut at some point or someone in
knew and NASA astronaut who said he
might be able to get Harry to the Space
Station I thought this would be so cool
if I literally get one of my pawns from
my own home and I can send him into
space bring him back to earth again and
get him back and he would have traveled
into space I mean like
on Harry the H porn into space that
would be that would be goods why is it
called a weather balloon does it go into
weather
I don't know is it weather plea I think
I use them they use them for weather
purposes okay right interesting position
so I'm gonna try to get my Knight to c4
it'd be easier just to buy a parrot if
you want to do saying crazy yeah you've
probably got point there to be honest
but I don't want to do saying crazy I
just thought would be quite good you
know be quite cool good a little bit of
advertisements you know a little bit of
stuff like that you know go get
something in what 5858 what did I miss
something there okay right so I'm hoping
now my point might have some sacrificial
ideas that don't really want to swap
Queens but you know needs must
occasionally and I can now this is my
main idea and you can probably like sack
it back or something like that I don't
know and I want to some you know my mud
my idea of my sac in the first place is
to get a little bit of pressure against
the b2 square of someone got 58 in
puzzle rush really bloody hell that's
not bad is it
someone got 58 in puzzle rush really
that's obscene who got 58 in puzzle rush
positive rush is like the crack cocaine
of the drug world isn't it it really is
everyone's going on about haha positive
rush I don't need to get my puzzle rush
fix you know give me give me a bit of a
rush if you know what puzzle rush is
well go go to chess calm and simply
search for puzzle rush it is the best is
really addictive hence why the crack
cocaine reference and it's where you
solve puzzles in a limited time limit
like five minutes maybe as quickly as
you can and it's it's really it's really
bloody kids okay now I did see this idea
but I have the move Knight to check I
think my opponent is going to be
too many pieces down now so yeah who who
the hell got that score that's insane
was it it was this guy spicy caterpillar
and has been a lot of talk about who is
spicy caterpillar um I'm thinking that
spicy caterpillar is probably an
American play this position estat a bit
weird oh Sh I don't like because
I can't get my Knights out he's got a
very good night here I think he's
probably like one of the young you can
go here and when his piece back as well
okay maybe it's not completely winning I
think he's probably I don't think it's
Magnus is it madness you think it's
Magnus someone's saying I think it's one
of the young American guys it could be
Magnus Carlsen of course it could be and
but I'm also thinking okay so my poets
got his piece back so this is not easy
now and I think it's probably like one
of the players Jeffery yacht solve was
that how you say someone like that
probably a young American no he's coming
in here my opponents suddenly playing
extremely well which is always annoying
when your opponent starts play extremely
well he's playing quite quick so let's
see if I can create something these
pawns because the thing is when you got
a rook when you've got a rook the extra
exchange you really want to try and use
that rook but it's not easy on open
lines rook work best on open lines but
it's very hard to get these rooks
working on open lines okay so he's
coming now this way I don't know I
thought his knight was better on d5
because now he's giving me this open
line potentially I mean this is just one
check so he's come back and now I'm
trying I'm gonna try and open up this
position okay now I have an idea I'm
gonna play here with the idea of
sacrificing back the exchange because I
have this kind of plant I had this clamp
over here around my opponent's king his
King cannot get out and the idea of
sacrificing back exchange the reason I
want to play a5 is I can now target this
port my
King is very active his King is cut off
for the ending and my king can try to
start taking pawns of course in the
ending the king is a very very dangerous
piece so well I'm just going to take me
to rook because I might as well just do
the Hoover job get my hover out my rook
is the Hoover at the moment there's not
hoovering those guys up and this is very
good ending for me now isn't it that's a
very good ending
let's go hoovering there is another pawn
I'm gonna Hoover as a bit greedy I
didn't really need to Hoover that one
out that was it there's a little bit too
greedy there but I've been greedy I'm
doing I'm doing it the Sarah wants a
round loves taking pawns and now I'll
call me back I'm coming back dude Oh in
a minute oh hang on a minute there sir
hang on a minute
what are you doing okay that was not a
good idea I played there I'm gonna have
to give myself a little bit of luth and
swapping Brooke should be good for me
because I have a lot of pawns how about
this let's try breakthrough can we do
this well I don't maybe I'll just grab
that one grab that one over there should
be good
should be good this for me I mean I am a
pawn up and this was the break for I was
trying to do so let this go for him then
he will come round and take my paw and I
take there interesting ending and
probably it's gonna it's gonna come down
to the clock isn't it this one
now c2 is a bit of a nasty trick here
where I'm attacking his rook and
threatening to Queen so okay thank you
for the game there that was one of the
better games my poke play very well
there I mean it looked like I was doing
doing okay I'm but then my opponent
fought back really well and he played he
played there's some part in that game he
kind of outplayed me my opponent say 20
so we're going to say 20 out playing a
grandmaster can't be too shabby you had
me a little bit worried no one's got me
terrified yet I'll tell you when someone
has me tell
fight or maybe one of you will just be
me is anyone gonna beat me or get a draw
today anyone there's anyone out there
brave enough to come and have a go so
remember if you want to play you have to
subscribe to the chess comm channel
loads of benefits you if you subscribe
to the channel you do get chance to play
me today and other grandmasters on other
sub sub days and you get loads of cool
emotes can't be too bad okay so let's
have a look at the chat and I'm gonna
have a little sip of wine as well
Saturday why I sit friends saying I like
how you talk about moves thank you very
much it's always nice to hear nice
comments so thank you
how often do I stream will I stream on
my own channel so go and follow my
channel twitch ginger GM is my nickname
ginger ginger you probably see where
that comes from GM Grand Master I've
tried a stream I'm trying to stream like
four times a week at the moment four or
five times so you come and do that and
I've got a youtube channel so go and
follow and subscribe to my youtube
channel over free videos there help your
chair some range of crazy stuff stop
making stupid people famous is what this
says I don't know I mean I know there's
too many I mean like dashians
gasps you know let's listen listen you
know geek is cool let's bring back the
chess I don't want to see any more
bickering bloody people chatting rubbish
Oh God bores me um okay let's look any
more chat coming through share Society
hello chess society another bunch of
streamers you should follow good guys it
seems to be very nice people the beard
looks dope Thank You Man I'm fortunate I
don't know if it's gonna grow any
further I was hoping to get a big a big
old mad one going but I'm not sure if
I'm gonna do it
so I'm any other comments lots of laughs
grease at eight I could win if I cheated
by looking at moose and the deep parrot
engine
the theme of today seems to be parrots
for some reason or another I don't know
where parrots came from so I think what
we're going to do in the next game we're
sort of halfway through - oh now I think
we're gonna try to make up oh this is a
great challenge we're gonna make up the
parrots opening so we're going for it
now making up a new opening is nearly
impossible I do believe there's
something like hello thank you for
subscribing chess Society very kind
there is something like 1600 divin
openings out there 1600 we're gonna make
it 1601 we're gonna make the parrot
opening so I'm gonna do this off the top
of my head I'm going to try to make up
an opening in the next game and we're
gonna try and just play some crazy Pat
the parrot Oakley any ideas what the
parrot opening should be it should be
something with their forces cruising
as that's the birds maybe the parrot
could be a variation in the birds I like
it cruzi I like unlike your I like it
okay this next game it's gonna be weird
I don't know how I'm gonna do I don't
know how I'm gonna do this one but I
like the idea something with the h-file
h4 h5 f for g5 it's gonna be interesting
what is the power opening gonna be I
need some inspiration down here on the
farm love that song UK subs great song
covered by Guns and Roses but the UK
subs version is a lot better okay
Sicilian parrot I give you advice about
the opening then I'd be it being my
opening yeah well look we're gonna make
it the parrot opening I'm gonna think
we've got a copy or opponents moves
because that's what parrot does maybe
maybe but we wouldn't be a bit of
regional night a free night be one oh
that's not a bad idea if the magic
dragon is saying okay should we try that
one okay I don't know one can do I've
got some ideas I've got some inspiration
so who is next we have Oh
Jen's chess you are next on the list I'm
beat I've got I've got a list of people
that I'm playing you have to be a sub to
this channel a subscriber and you have
to be on chess calm
we are and Jen's chess I've lost two
before
Jen's chess is a very dangerous player
but Jen's chess you are now coming up
against the parrot
are you ready Jen's chess okay so what
the hell was the parrot guys I don't
know
so what are we gonna do okay now what I
think the parrot should be I think
unlike cruzi Lee it should be a
variation of the birds and I think the
parrot should be g4 boom the power
opening there we come okay so this is
the parrots probably one of the worst
openings in the history of openings f4
f5 g4 the parrots so we've made up the
parrot there we go we've created some
art now I'm probably gonna get
completely smashed in this game
especially if my opponent gets his Queen
over here so it is the parrots this is
the spire who you phone why is there a
diamond icon next your name Simon um I
don't know actually chess Society I've
got no idea
I've got honestly don't know I think I
am a diamond member I'm pretty sure
about that I don't know I honestly don't
know the answer we'll look at this let's
go let's take that one and be brave if
you're gonna play like a parrot you have
to be a brave parrot you can't be a
parrot who and then we have to go here
this is the parrots I have to be honest
guys I don't know if I'm going to be
playing this in any of my future
tournaments it looks a little bit
dangerous okay and now Jen's is coming
in with this move okay so I have to go
d4 I don't want the night come in there
I need to try and develop my pieces what
is this opening its the parrot that's
what it is I know that as we've made up
what an opening well it is okay now
Jen's are trying to come at me from the
sides
calm down Jen's you don't want to defeat
the parrot do you get the parrot the
respect it deserves please sir give him
that okay so what are we going to do now
well I could go see for to spot that
or I could try and get my king somewhere
a little bit safer so I think I'm gonna
go here with the idea of moving my King
around this way because it's not all bad
this position is not all bad the
positive about this position is I have a
very big Center look at those guys I
have free porn in the center so if I can
stabilize I'll be alright by the way
this is all theory this is all theory
this is you know I've studied this me
and magnus carlsen had a training
session and the power a couple years ago
we just didn't know it is called the
parrot we looked at this opening I'm
surprised he didn't play it against
Fabiana in his World Championship match
that was the only shocking thing but we
did we did study this is it's all in the
books you know I know exactly what I'm
Dave Magnus said Matt you know what
Magnus said to me about this one he said
Simon very imaginative opening all we
need to do now is give it an appropriate
name and now we have an appropriate name
Thank You Magnus okay so I'm going to go
here this is the parrot porn and what
the parrot porn does it tents itself
into being capturing because then you
can go d5 and you can fork him the
forking parrot comes to life okay now
what the hell is going on I still don't
know he's gonna take here he's taking
here he's checking here my king but I'm
gonna take a piece let's take a piece
it's a fearless parrot too this one it
is okay it was I mean I'm pretty sure
this was all magnet Magnus had this prep
Magnus knows everything he even knows
about the parrot so I think my challenge
today should be get as many parrot
openings in as I darn well can yeah okay
the only thing I still don't like is my
king so developing looks like a good
idea and next move I'll go here attack
his queen I wanted to bring my knight
here first cuz I'm defending that porn
so when I do attack his Queen his queen
can't come over here and
give me a little bit of grief yet stock
this is saying save this game and send
it to a chess club to teach the kids
no don't this it this comes with one of
those warnings you see on you know like
DVDs or you know the start of a
television show you sometimes get like
the announcement the announcement is
this program contains violence scenes of
a sexual nature
well this opening here it does actually
have all those issues okay now what the
hell is going on my opponent has very
good plan I've just realized that with
his queen coming here he might be
grabbing the rook so I don't know
because I can now no longer Kate Knight
f3 because he's put his knight in a very
good position so I might be losing that
poor guy there which is a little bit
upsetting I agree oh we're not going to
lose with a parrot are we we're not
going to lose with a parrot I can't come
on parrot don't let me down do not let
me down the parrot you know it's your
first outing and Angie you know you got
it okay so I can play in this position
Queen e2 with the idea of going Bishop
here and getting the bishop to that very
nice diagonal I'll tell you I'll tell
you a funny story actually and I did
used to teach chess in schools and I
like one of the first things I taught
the kids was don't bring your queen out
too early and then you know these some
of these kids are quite keen so they'd
watch some of the games their favorite
players and they they the next time I
came back in chess club one of them
start moving his queen out early and I
was like wait I thought we said you
shouldn't bring your queen early I gave
him a little slap no I didn't really
junk in it's not even joke is it's no
funny I'm not funny I'm chess player
chess players they must be funny and so
I said wait bring it we know that you
shouldn't do that should you should you
bring it clearly and he goes well well
Simon I saw Hikaru Nakamura doing this
and I was like what any car route
started again Eve
for a five queen h5 and then he car is
start moving his queen about you won the
game and this kid was like I saw a car
oh do it must be good
Hikaru did actually do it and I was like
yeah well yeah you got a point there I
was like thanks Hikaru
thanks mate for for destroying okay
destroying okay so alright so I'm just
I'm trying to think here so I've got
ideas now bring the rook out here and
also Bishop g2 Queen a6 my porn does a
great job the parrot is it gonna win is
the parrot going to win Thank You stevis
for subscribing so I will get my rook
out here this looks like a nice
defensive and aggressive square and I
get it off the fret and I have ideas now
of bringing my Queen in and going for
checkmate let's do that shall we
ah this is the para attack I'm sorry I
did forget my fairy me and Magnus I know
we did actually look at this in all our
day in our days and we did come to the
conclusion that this maneuver was one of
the most important maneuvers that you
have to remember in the parrots and as
soon as you get this in you have an
unstoppable attack and there's nothing
in the world that black can do the
reason I'm talking very slowly is I am
trying when my piece up I am Pisa okay
that's all right
I think the parrot is looking good yeah
is the parent looking good guys okay now
is this gonna lead to mate he's gonna
take here so I'm just gonna move this
one out the way because otherwise my
King might be game parroted now he's got
a check here that's a little bit a
little bit annoying there's only one
check I'm trying to get into his king
bed this is my this is my idea it looks
good doesn't it but this is annoying
check I can't block so I have to try
he's got a check over here then do I
come this way so I've got to be a little
bit careful here guys it could go wrong
parrot is still walking he's still
walking okay now he's trying to come to
stop it man stop trunk checkmate me okay
oh he's gonna go there and checkmate
this is how did he manage this what has
he done to me
okay can I counter attack oh god I'm a
time no no I'm a little bit worried I'm
a little bit worried I'm trying to
survivor this but my time is atrocious
is this defending is it defending I
don't know very very good counter attack
by my opponent who's has come at me but
I think I'm just about holding on here
and now if I take here wow he's still
coming at me calm down man Jen's why sir
why are you so mad man what stop it man
just stop attacking me will you give it
a break sir you don't attack me anymore
you've had your fun you've had your fun
stop it James
okay I feel I feel like I am getting out
of this one on the rook up and I feeling
a lot happier now there was some scare
all we could take it he does but okay
I've still the exchange up and my
position is still very good don't lose
the other that beat yeah don't lose that
one as well or perish but that is that
what parent noises that Matt can oh and
I love a parrot
okay the parrot does the job a hundred
percent with the parrots can anyone
claim anything else have any openings
the parents all theory what a well that
was that was a nerve-wracking game
wasn't it that one that was a
nerve-wracking game okay so let's just
have a look at the chow just scroll up a
little bit
welp if I did manage to get King b1 and
Bishop c1 him it was a little bit scary
at the end how did I manage that well
the parrot can do many wonderful things
para opening is already a legend yes
that it is
dear people it's got a hundred percent
it's doing well how did you get that out
of I don't know how do I get out that I
don't know it was a weird opening thank
you for game by the way
Jones chess Jen's Jen's chess played
very well especially at the end of the
game there Jen's was doing a lot of you
know a lot of yeah it was I agree with
weary oh Lord Jen chess placed so great
yay did he played very good game there
and that was cool the hippo opening
carrot with black a slight overdose of
parrot says Jones chess
well done on a good game by the way
judge Jessie you've nearly had me there
GM Joey is the most famous chess playing
parent okay no book moves with plate so
it isn't your piece we've made a new
opening can we confirm can we confirm
we've actually made a new opening today
so the parrots is f4 f5 g4 is this the
first time that g4 has ever been played
as if it is I am queening this the
parrot we are we are going to coin it
the parrot no games found yes we found a
new move on move to now the probability
of that and I'm not a mathematician is
bloody large I know that to find a
novelty and what I mean by novelty a
move that's never been played in the
history of chess in the history of chess
or move to to get a unique position out
of the tens of millions of games they
recorded is very rare so gents chess you
create a piece of history with me there
gents well done well done well done
gents you you have created a bit of
history and so did you cruise the
cruiser you did I'll give you a little
bit of credit you you are we can call it
the crew Z parrots variation how about
that the crew Z parrots so we have we
create some history
oh well down to the history okay good
stuff
okay so who's next now so I've still won
every game is anyone gonna take me down
come on guys
is anyone gonna take me down come on
okay so next up we have Jackie the Swede
and then Mary hat man who was a bit of a
group player and Jackie the Swede you
are next and do we have oh oh we have a
chance to play the power again
come on parrots we need to get two out
two with a parrot will Jackie play a
five
oh no Jackie you have not done it but
you know what the parrot is not scared
we're going for the power anyway here it
is f4 and g4 against everything it's set
for a five because then Queen h4 might
be checkmate so this is the parrots
again it's the parrot ah ah ah that's my
best bird noise just in case you're
wondering what what the hell I was doing
there okay so now look at the parrot
porn the parrot porn is flying up the
board flying up the board here it comes
and yep who's gonna be the first person
to write a book on this opening well I'm
not gonna release Magnus's secret work
that he did on this opening I think
that'd be a bit disrespectful to the
world champion I don't think he'd be
happy if I released his secret notes on
this you know we've got to respect the
world champion homey okay so what about
this okay this is just weirdness now can
I go here and trap and trap Jackie's
night I mean this is one of the basic
parrot traps this is something every
schoolboy in Godalming where I come from
those this is the parrot trap you create
a web of deception around your
opponent's night you force it into a
position where it cannot escape and then
you slowly with your pawns weave it's
eternal doom and that night is doomed to
be removed from the board the parrot I
feel may be claiming yet another victim
go parrot go and is it he just fallen
into one of the most
well-known parrot trips trips traps or
trips I think this is a bit trippy chess
isn't it but and there we go we've won
we look at it the power of pawns
they are just unstoppable unstoppable
unstoppable pawns coming down the board
okay so what are we going to do next
well I think we're a piece up so I'm
going to stop him playing a 5 by getting
hold of the e5 square do you remember
guys I have my own twitch channel if you
want to see me playing chess if you're
sick of me playing chess like understand
that if you're thinking this guy's this
guy is just like complete and utter
lunatic and I have to warn you if you do
watch my twitch streams you may improve
or you may just lose weight and if you
try to copy the parrot I mean it does
come it does come with a health warning
you know let's just put it out there it
is a health warning but this is another
parrot trip I say trip now track trap
can I talk Knight b5 and now we're
coming into c7 so 10 moves were
completely winning completely winning c3
nice and calm the Queen has nowhere to
go
and we're gonna take care we're gonna
take here and we're gonna be like 10
points up or saying I mean look at it
look at these guys look at them go so
look they look so nice they're all like
they'd all like looking after each other
over there they're all looking Oh what's
he doing now is he giving up his queen
he's been totally thrown by the parrots
and I could just take the Queen it has
that effect on people and now he's
giving up that one I think I think my
opponents got more barking mad than me
and maybe Jackie is now gonna start
counting the pieces and realize that he
doesn't have too many left in this
situation and oh I like that move right
what is a good move here people anyone
see a good move rook takes h7 yeah I
know there's another move
oh now I've just all he resigned ah ah
ah well this this my dear this brilliant
sacrifice is that when he takes my rook
here I go Queens a a checkmate amazing
sacrifice well at this this is yeah
obviously I could play that straightaway
and checkmate thank you for the game
Jackie the Swede and you just you just
basically came across the parrot man
what can you do
no one is now got two out with two two
wins out the two the new train the
opening we're gonna see this with this
opening is going to take off two
attitude with a parrot okay so now I
have Mary hat man Martin who follows a
lot of my strange maybe if you want to
check out my streams it's a twitch.tv
just such a ginger GM ginger yeah red
ginger GM and I've got on streaming
tomorrow so you guys can you know come
come and come and give me a bit of a bit
of support as well okay right so let's
get it on Martin now I think we're gonna
have a little rest from the parrot good
I've got the black pieces thank goodness
for that oh oh no come on Martin are you
okay is he gonna play the parrot after
f5 is he gonna play it he's come for it
what the hell is going on today guys
Martin you are one brave one brave man
oh my worse I mean Martin has gone for
the parrot and now I've got a
confliction I've got a big confliction
here
do I really want to win this game do I
really want to win this one I don't know
if I win this one against my baby my
baby parrots it feels like animal
cruelty or something do I want to do one
really want to be do I really want to
kill the parents I want to keep my
hundred-percent though so I have to I
have to ah you are you Martin you are
one brave man playing the Paris against
the founding father and now well okay I
think the best move here is to go here
setting up a bit of a trick and this
check over here is coming Martin moving
very confidently
I mean what is this madness guys okay
let's come in should we come in or
should we just take we'll take that one
so the parrots the parents I mean do you
think this has got a future this opening
who thinks this has a future anyone okay
so I have this check my opponent could
be okay I've got to give a check we
could we got a play we got to play
aggressively and now I'm gonna get my
night outs I'm gonna get a route to this
square but I don't know I mean the
parrot the parrot is it we're gonna have
to study this line a little bit more
we're gonna have to study this one I
mean has my opponent has got the center
again Marting has got the center so the
parrot is fighting in the center of the
board is doing its job there don't
defeat it says Feeny warm-up but you
reckon I should offer a draw I can't I
can't I mean maybe I maybe if I get to a
winning position I should offer a draw
maybe this is maybe this is the solution
all Martin you're really asking all dear
this is move six and things are looking
a little bit dodgy for the parrot oh
dear night chief
okay I'm gonna have to offer it amassing
a draw because we just can't we can't we
can't have we can't have the parrot
being late we can't lose you know this
is the only draw I'm gonna give away
today I've offered him a draw
he's taking it I'm sorry guys come on I
can't defeat the power let me off this
one time I mean the one time I mean I
can't I can't let's can't do it you know
would you kill your own child would you
you know we shouldn't if you want to do
that you know you know and the idea is
obviously to go check and here so the
parrot still has two and a half out of
three against Grandmaster opposition we
like it
not bad yes you ruined the 100% but you
still got a draw against the Grandmaster
so well done jolly good show our boy and
I think this is really completely loss
of white now the Knights coming here
Knights taking this it's pretty
disgusting pretty okay well I've had
enough parrot action I need I need to
have a break from the parrot for a
little bit you know
you know the parrot is it's time to have
a little break so remember guys if you
want to play and what you have to do you
have to be a subscriber to this channel
chess channel do cut good do go and
check out my own channel ginger GM check
out my youtube videos i do stream myself
and you had to be on chest comm as well
and we're gonna try to play as many
people as we can and next up we have
ante back so ante back hello there and
let's get it on ante back ante back from
Norway
one of the most chess loving nations in
the world
so prior role ook thank you for
subscribing I'm not I'm not picking the
people I play by the way I've got list
of players but if you are a subscriber
you should you should get a game against
me ok so what are we gonna do here well
I think we're gonna go for a bit of
Kings India oh that was a bit of a mouse
lit but now I'm looking at that Paul
come into that square I'm thinking or
maybe maybe maybe I should be maybe you
know maybe that was 0 double-oh-seven
bunny thank you for subscribing I'm
actually now thinking about let's see if
we can make up another opening so that
I'm meant to so I'm gonna play the Kings
Indian put the pawn there but now my
opponents put the bishop there I'm gonna
play this little move so this is I like
it the Raven the Raven opening and the
idea is the fro Gary up the board I mean
what is this what is this what is this
so yeah so I am playing been fine gold
in a match in under two weeks now and I
lost the last match I'm gonna try to get
more revenge in this one I'm Ben's a
good laugh but I'm feeling very
confident and I think I will definitely
win this one I'm gonna take it a lot
more seriously than last time so we'll
see
but yeah I mean it's going to be a close
match it's going to be a close match
well what I'm planning to do here I
think I had a plan do I have a plan do I
have a plan guys well I want my whole
plans energy five is this in your
opening is this being played before
can someone can someone check this I
don't know maybe maybe it's new maybe
it's not new I don't know I honestly
don't know if this is new or not we're
trying to create new openings today so I
think I'm going to have to prepare it
because at the moment my opponent is
guarding the g5 square so we're gonna
we're gonna prepare it and we're gonna
get Gary motoring up the ball go on Gary
I guess my king will have to just stay
in the middle or castle over here so
okay so I want to defend that pawn a
little bit I don't want anything nasty
happening there so we do this my bishop
can come out as well cry like a ginger
Grandmaster a porn crusher it's saying
and so I obviously think he obviously
thinks I'm gonna go down and I'm gonna
cry
well maybe I will if I lose the pimp
I'll be the first chess streamer to turn
into a bubbling mess of tears there's
anyone else crying I mean nothing wrong
crying I have to say a thing there's a
bit of a okay I'm gonna play like a
hedgehog this one is coming the the
Raven I like that so good name the Raven
so we're just gonna we're just gonna
wait for the Raven pause Khandala boar
that's cool name isn't it
ginger GM Ravens don't cry Ravens are
too hardcore so here we go now it come
the Raven comes g5 there's definitely
some bird related madness going on today
and my opponent is playing very well
very good moves and I think getting
ready to play efore so I'm gonna try to
stop that move by getting my knight to
that square and you can see this is the
kind of stuff I played before you know
this kind of this kind of malarkey okay
so we're gonna take that one from off
you off offer your head oh boy that's
what they used to say at Ravens
obviously in the Tower of London
are are linked and there's this I think
there's a was that the legend is as soon
as the Ravens leave the Tower of London
London will fall does that right
something like that who knows about that
and of course yes some was pointed out
Raven and egg we're Popo and his Raven
and the Simpsons version that is very
good as well like that Feingold is
already trash-talking his streams well
you should have watched my stream
yesterday he might trash talk the same
old jokes every day of his life I
mean it he literally you know but he
hasn't invented an opening called the
parrot has he he hasn't opened he hasn't
invented the parrots there's only
there's only one person that's me so he
can come up with his same old jokes
regurgitated time and time again but you
know come on Ben use that imagination
get your dad jokes out of the way
everyone's heard your dad jokes they're
old they're too old so anyway we'll see
and I you know I don't I don't
necessarily need to trash talking
because you know why why do I you know
let's let's let the chest do the talking
I think that's the best that's the best
thing to do okay so the Raven porn is
going well and I think it's now time to
get my King castled and I want to get
the Raven March going so I can open up
the G file so my opponent trying to do
some attacking over here so what about
f5 and GG for that seems like a good
idea yeah
okay so and now I will take this night
off because I really like my bishop
there my bishop is really really good
and this bishop combined with my rook is
trying to land a bit of a bit of a blow
down there on g2 and remember if you are
watching this people at home you can't
play me you know you can't you can't get
a chance to play Grandmaster if you
subscribe to the chess twitch channel
just press the subscribe and then
subscribe to my channel as well and you
can get a chance to play me so do do
come on come on come and come and play
guys come and play okay so my opponents
holding it together well and maybe this
move is coming up next so I'm gonna play
rook here give me some chances maybe to
push my port and that's a good
positional move for my opponent why
because it blocks out the bishop on b7
but I'm gonna go e5 and this is
consistent with my idea of trying to use
my pawns to to march out the board I
mean I think first of all I will go King
here first because I like I like it when
all my pieces are like coordinating well
and the idea of this my bishop is dead
now on this square so I kind of like the
idea bring it back to c8 when it might
have potential later on to come out over
here so good my point well could play
for my pilot trying to attack say I
really want to play this move but I
can't at the moment so another thing I'm
looking at a dear old Harry boy over
here Harry the H pawn is looking a
little bit eager to be taken so if I go
Queen d8 can I go monkey monkey monkey
you might all look at this calm down you
know I see what you're trying to do just
chill chill please chill a little bit
chill just just relax please
don't kill me don't kill me okay so you
know I'm still quite I'm still quite
happy because
Harry you know I've won herion oh and
now now now it's now it's coming now
it's coming look at this the Raven the
Raven is raving the raving Raven a nice
poem in the mark of a Guapo by the Jin
Jim raving a raven okay so I think this
one is winning a piece I'm actually I
didn't realize how short time I will say
I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to move
a little bit quicker here but this
Bishop his trap look how good look at
how good the Raven has performed I mean
look at that is it's done such a brave
brave March its marched all the way down
to h2 and I have a very nice checkmate
coming up if my opponent is and this
well can i chip mike and checkmate in a
couple of ways it bishop f2 is clearly
very strong because I win the Queen so
I'll keep it simple and this is the
checkmate I was sort of looking for but
my opponent has one defense so thank you
for the game auntie back you play very
well death um you came at me on the
Queen side London system great opening
maybe one of the mistakes was the big
mistake probably was around here to let
my porn get to where for I mean as soon
as I get my porn there it's a little bit
a little bit dangerous so we're creating
new openings I like this for coming
we're coming with the Raven okay so who
is next so remember if you want to play
we're into the last hour of playing now
and all you have to do is subscribe and
get in chess comm join the queue and you
probably get to play grandmas that no
one has defeated me the only draw came
about by the parrots opening a very
famous opening that's we can expect to
see a lot more of in the future
especially at super Grandmaster level
Magnus Cara wanna
manager off karyakin or carjacking as is
sometimes known all these people will be
playing it soon so there's some look um
so thank you for subscribing and and
someone subscribed there thank you I
missed to it was I'm afraid but thank
you for subscribing to this channel and
to do do you never get tired from using
your brain so intensely I'm absolutely
shattered at the moment and my brain
might actually explode at any second but
that would be some damn good
entertainment went it's chess is a very
very exhausting game I mean it really is
tag born thank you for subscribing and
everyone else so who we got next sin so
let's have a look so we have quite a bit
Q so I'm gonna try to get through you
guys as quickly as I can and we have
Simone Johansson I think is that how you
say it from Norway and we're gonna we're
gonna we're just gonna give the parrot a
little bit of a break because this poor
parrot needs needs to have a little
little a little rest now and again oh
I'm sorry I'm just I'm my pouch just
give me a comment and I I didn't
actually read it so I'm sorry about that
salicylate is quite a long comment and
it is hello and welcome to not normal
game chess here are the rules
the point of this game is to build a
base you can build a parrot base instant
the first 15 moves I used to build the
base no let me just put this in the chat
this is a lot to read I don't know if
I'm going to do this by the way guys but
this is what my opponent has kind of
sent me and so a base your first 15 is
used to build the base no moves beyond
your for Frank and no captures allowed
aesthetics are important after 15 moves
the base is built and the chat will give
score from one to ten on how beautiful
the base looks then we play I like this
this is really cool then we play a
normal game chess but one interception
the chat will also give a score from 1
to 10 so
let me get this right I'll do this for
this game for the first ten moves we
can't go past the fourth rank and we
just got a crate as pretty a position as
we can and you guys are gonna judge it
and then we can place no chess we play
one game like this I like it
so let's do it so okay so the first ten
mill was it first 15 miss I'm trying to
think what pattern I want to creates now
so what pattern do I want to create
well that is there's a darn good
question 15 moves yeah I don't know I'm
thinking about a beautiful pattern it I
tell you what in honor of the
caterpillar was it spicy caterpillar who
has just got an amazing he's broken all
the records on chess compiz rush I'm
gonna create a caterpillar opening okay
so it's gonna be a little bit like this
because that's kind of how caterpillar
moves isn't it a little bit like this so
I'm going to create a caterpillar so
here we go okay so the first 15 moves
move - now obviously we've got to create
the most beautiful position we can and
then after 15 moose we play a game of
chess so here's my caterpillar can you
see my caterpillar
here it is and we move five now here
comes the caterpillar here it comes here
comes the cat oh can I go there you
actually can't take he's not gonna take
is he and now and now okay I'm still
scared look this is this is kind of
pretty and now okay now he's going for
that he's just going to the hippo he's
playing very normally and now remove
10th and okay so who's gonna get the
more beautiful position I'm gonna move
this one over here ah look at this the
caterpillar this is what I'm thinking of
he is playing the hippo he's just going
for the hippo you know I have to say
Simone the hippo is quite a normal
opening there and I'm now I've done the
first Tim moose we can't go past the
four Frank his rules it will move 15 but
I'm gonna get ready we're Harry
now the caterpillar slowly comes it
slowly comes
we're on move thirteen now oh now he's
doing some little funky maneuvering that
y'all need to get my night over this
side of the board don't lie so let's go
here now I'm gathering he won't take
that because that's breaking the rules
of engagement that is breaking the rules
of engagement you cannot take that one
it's your own rules sir do not capture
that night because it's breaking the
rules you might beat me but you're
breaking your own rules okay and now
look at this all my pieces are very snug
we've got and this is move 15 we can now
play I want to get my king here my queen
here doh I don't know okay so so now
guys you have to score Ramu 15 out of 10
first of all my setup and then my
opponent setup so we can play now yep I
think so huh what do you reckon
who's that who's got this one I think
the caterpillar is done all right I
think I've created some nice little look
at it I've got rid of all my pieces from
this area to board I think that's the
least I think it's at least a 5.4 5.4 no
it must be an 8 is more high in there
oh come on a 8 out you only get you only
go I said 8 I actually meant 10 Martin
you'll give me an 8 and you give my
opponent of 5 we've got 7 and a half of
1 a 1 we've only got a 1 7 for Simon 10
for ginger all right ok so my opponent
Simone yes sir we can play now and the
chat can also give a mark on how
beautiful the checkmate is so now I'm
going for the kill with the hairy port
so here we come Simon you need to play
you have no time I still have ok
why not take that one ok so it's not a
normal game clearly um what is this
madness that's going on today I mean
this show started off quite normal and
it is a Saturday night show I guess so
um ok I think my opponents trying to
help me create a beautiful checkmate ok
so I see I see I see so he's on purpose
losing but in order for me to create a
checkmate ok I get I get the way he's
trying to try and do this so it's not a
proper game it's on the Beauty side of
it so
I've got to think how I want to
sacrifice my queen here this is how
we're gonna try to create some beauty
okay so I'm gonna try to do that I'm
gonna get my queen here and sack it on
h7 this is my idea for the beauty prize
so how are we gonna do this well I need
to get my bishop out the way I don't
take the rook and going there's a bit
boring but only if I checkmate in the
normal way I've got I got it I got an
idea
it is a free night but we're not playing
normal chess now this is normal
checkmate but I'm not with this is a
beauty game this is that we're going for
the beauty price so my idea is to sack
the Queen on h7 and then take here so
this is what I'm gonna try to achieve
I'm not gonna checkmate him here cuz
it's too plain easy I want to try to
create the beauty price take here take
here so I need to set this one up okay
my opponent is playing like an animal
and okay so how do we set it up well I
think I need this pawn here takes takes
takes okay I'm getting ready I'm getting
there we're going for the beauty price
we're going oh no he's gonna take my
rook don't take my rope if you take my
rook it spoils my whole oh no he's gonna
take my work he's gonna take my rug oh
yeah he hasn't okay so now we got it you
ready you ready you ready for the beauty
price we're not going Queen g7 we are
gonna go Queen h7 oh I've got a play
normal game of chess office this is just
like mind messing up boom double check
is the double this a dabbler it's a
double checker and can you see what's
coming next
if it had taken that one I had rook h6
and I think we're gonna put him out of
his misery there rook H a what I don't
know that was just weird that was weird
guys thank you for the game some Oh UK
that was a totally unique idea that I've
never had anyone come with an idea like
that before so so 10 out of 10 for your
uniqueness now you've got a you guys
have got to mark that out ten points for
there for the chip mate and boom is the
way or the walk ten out of ten six but
it's better than the one you gave before
isn't it at least I'm moving up in the
world
at least I'm moving up so the idea of
the checkmate here was if he took here
and this one is checkmate but okay thank
you for that six point eight okay I like
it
who's next Center so rights to do that
okay so we're gonna go for stevis five
and you are next on the list then after
Steve is 5 we have woods
Jeanne Pryor Oh Luke and we're gonna
keep going for now I try to get through
you a bit more no one has defeated me
yet we need a normal game of chess now
because otherwise my brain is just gonna
my brain is just gonna explode
so what opening we gonna play though so
we haven't had me playing d5 yet so I'm
gonna play d5 normal sensible chess
everyone plays the bloody London system
nowadays don't they
every single person plays the London
system so we're gonna play a normal game
of chess nothing funny going on here
sensible moves you know nothing nothing
out of course and I'm going to sack a
pawn this is the the Willie Williams
gambit my surname as you may guess
there's Williams and it's the Willie
Williams gambit so here we go
nice normal game of chess I suppose I
don't know is it so stupid I get one
tempo to attack it probably as stupid as
she it probably is just absolutely
ridiculous because I get the same
position but without a porn here hmm
yeah I don't like the Willie Williams
gambit we might have to we might have to
you know give this one a little bit of a
wide wide birch should we say the Willie
Williams gambit is not gonna it's not
gonna have many takers is it this one I
don't think so but ok later on I might
have this file for the attack you've
always got to look as as you know Monty
Python set on the bright side of life
always look on the bright side of chess
there we go okay so that's the bright
side so I think we're gonna now do this
little subtle maneuver there we go where
Oh
putting it up we are opening up this is
the deferred grappa I think it's more of
an accelerated Grob isn't it Mary you
just give up a pawn straight away for a
bit of craziness yeah okay so I don't to
leave that don't lose this guy so I'm
gonna move my queen because I think
castling looks fairly straightforward
and sensible here as well and I hope my
if my point castles King side lease
we're gonna get double edged game there
always look on the bright side a
checkmate I like that one
that's that's a good good saying as well
there sir and if your fish could talk I
would turn off the mute well thank you
for that very kind comment if fish could
talk I wouldn't be sitting here I'd be
chilling out of the ocean listening to
all their magical whims lines on life I
believe your fish could talk if fish
could talk what would they say they'd
probably say you horrible human kind
stop stop it of your plant I don't want
to know I do I wouldn't want to know
what they'd say to be honest I just
wouldn't I just wouldn't want to know if
fish could talk well yeah okay anyway
right so I think now look look lit
actually this gambit the Willy Williams
gambit is not looking so bad okay I like
that if fish could talk they would say
stop going to the toilet in the water
that's a good one that's it yeah that's
a good one that is a good one okay I'm
just reading some messages as we go
along and you know we do have 40 minutes
left of the show about I think that's
obviously do you swim here often you cut
you guys you guys come up with some good
ones I like it you guys come out some
good ideas okay so I'd love to try to
get this move in rook takes g2 with some
kind of checkmate but my opponent always
has the bishops g-free to block up the G
file so I think for the time being
rather than playing something like Queen
a ch3 bishop g3 I need to try and prove
my pieces a little bit more so the move
that sort of is obvious to me is Knight
to e4 just because I like my knight in
the center of the board my bishop might
bear to come out I might be to play e5
and then maybe soon I can try to double
rooks on the Willie Williams g5
something like that
is it it's quite similar to some of
those lines is it Mary Hammond I suppose
it is but white does have the pawn on d4
maybe it is maybe maybe it is I mean
it's a bit of it yeah I like that very
fishy variation I mean the tangents
we've gone on today with the
conversation has been quite impressive
parrots fish I mean where are we gonna
go next
where's this going guys I don't know
okay so well I mean this looks all right
to me this position I might also start
using Harry because I feel like if I get
my pull onto this square you know I can
increase the pressure on my opponent's
Kings side so I just want to you know I
want to get this somewhere like there
maybe Getty five in and start some kind
of attack against g2 this kind of stuff
that is what we're gonna do what is the
command for this game rules I don't
quite understand that one when is buzz
boom joining were you over in batavia
amps down with me there Thank You gods
92 I don't know I'm oh I can take that
now he's really making it tempting for
me to take it if I miss something is he
trying to trick me when you see an
obvious move you should kind of like
smell a rat or think that is fishy as a
fishy move salmon Williams all I lecture
society but I can't see anything wrong
with Queen takes h3 taking a pawn and
threatening checkmate
and if you can't see anything wrong with
something I was he gonna go Knight g5 is
that his idea
so Queen takes it Knight g5 Knight takes
g5 Bishop g4 check interesting f5 Queen
takes their Knight takes H free check
other got two pawns for the piece he's
also trying to get the bishop to the
square clearly but takes it Knight g5 I
can come back to d7 there that's
interesting let let's see let's see this
looks like the most interesting move so
I think my opponents very imaginative
idea is this move so that's one of the
most imaginative ideas that I think
we've actually seen today I have to be
honest giving up a pawn to start this
counter-attack so I have to give credit
to my opponent for I love I love it when
people play these imaginative
interesting unique ideas and this is the
fret and my queen so I'm gonna move the
Queen all the way back to try to stop
Bishop Higgs now I can block it with a
pawn coming to one of these two squares
but I like that imagine if I did
imaginative idea okay I did spot your
idea STIs stevis you know I'm not a
grandmaster for nothing son you know we
asked grandmasters ask grandmasters we
can spot these things occasionally okay
now I can take that night but can I also
attack because maybe we have to take
that one now Bishop here I still have e6
so I'm okay we're gonna have to take
that night sooner or later on me I have
to go here wiser lose McQueen and my
opponent very shorter time at the moment
say this is obviously when you're gonna
when you're playing an imaginative way
it does require more time to think so
and also now
I'm starting to get some dangerous frets
that was a fret and if I can get my
queen around here which I'm going to try
to do I have ideas of night h3 and Queen
takes g2 so my opponents spotted that
one and I have other ideas trying to get
the Queen in this way or trying to take
on g3 at some moment so my idea now is
to take here and take on G free but
let's try because I mean I'm probably
gonna be winning on time anyway I don't
think this works because the Queen g2 so
I'm probably losing here actually after
Queen g2 because I forgot I can't take
here cuz he takes my rip but okay I'm I
am winning on time so yep time came and
I probably had some better way to do can
I beat could I play a game against Eric
Rosen someone saying in the chat yeah I
mean I'd love to start doing some more
rivals YouTube videos if there's any
other it was it by the way it was a good
game is a very interesting game Stevie I
mean that was one of the more
imaginative games and you were you're
winning at the end there so you could
take that away from that game so I could
have played that better definitely at
times but well done to my opponent Steve
is so coming up very interesting idea h3
one of the most interesting ideas of the
day so I mean I'm all up for playing
against you no other title plays anyone
it's good to have challenges rival
matches but then in two weeks is
obviously gonna be the big one so I
probably won't do much until then okay
so next up we have woods Jeannie I had
the white pieces so what opening have we
not tried so far well I haven't played
this one be free be free and this is
quite an interesting opening this is
played by a georgian player called
gabbatha which you may or may not know
and the point of this one is to attack
the center from the sights so I'm
threatening to win that pawn because I'm
pinning the night and you get some very
interesting positions
now I can play F for putting pressure on
that one and if that pawn moves I can
take on g7 so I'm trying to attack the
center from from the sides basically I
see I dare this one that is your idea so
my opponent is defending that one and
now I'm going to develop an attack that
one so I have quite a lot of pressure 1
2 3 attacking here my opponent has won
two free defending in order to win a
pawn that square you have to have more
this is I think a theoretical position
you can now take take and after Bishop
taste try some check but I seem to
recall that that's not a very good idea
for me because when I take here and he
takes back moving this pawn his Knight
has a very good square on f6 so I'm
going to just try to develop and create
more frets develop pieces attack things
create frets that's the way to go that's
the way to go
so trans dot is saying barring barring
barring channel and so thank you for
your contribution it was nice to have
people like that coming on I mean yeah I
mean oh the great thing about switching
the Internet is if you don't like a
channel you can actually just like go to
another channel rather than type in it I
find it really weird when people like no
I've seen this before people sort of say
oh I hate this channel and then like
five minutes later they're like oh yeah
this channel is like rubbish then an
hour goes by and they're like oh this is
such a bad channel and then when you've
done a to free our stream they're still
there saying how much they hate it even
though they've been there for like two
three hours listening to the whole
Channel I mean what is wrong with them
you know just like really are you
actually insane you don't turn it off
you're not forced to watch this
you just watch find it quite amusing it
was quite quite funny okay so what do we
can think we're not I dunno I mean I can
take care quite initialization I'd like
to get my bishop to e4 as well but if I
go Bishop d3 can he play e4 then if I
cancel that looks like fun so let's try
cuz if I get a chance this is a very
nice square for the bishop so I think he
should play E for and then I'm gonna
Castle and all hell will break loose and
all hell will break loose F okay so he's
gone back so now I'm quite happy because
I think with my porn coming here you
won't ever move my bishop so I'm just
gonna castle and put my porn on D free
and I kind of got a weird little
structure there I don't know if it's
good or bad let's go for it let's go for
it okay so I'm not playing tonight it's
it's nearly it's nearly 11 o'clock over
here in England and I did stay out a
little bit late last night being a
Friday night with my friends Lea and
Blair so I said we're not doing arrivals
tonight man gate you know I need I need
I need to get my rest my brain might
just explode ah I'll do it another time
I promise but you've got to let me sleep
man at some point come on I'm not a
workhorse you know my brain needs to
have some rest okay so anyway that's the
chest and we do it well I'm gonna
now let's truck I've been can I go there
or no I've got a couple of ideas the
other idea is to maybe just to increase
my space on the queenside
because if he does decide to cancel that
way I mean you from watching this show
you probably see the way I play chess
I'll be ready to push the port at the
boar now that's a bit of annoying move
because it's night it's coming in here I
don't want that to occur so I'm just
gonna defend that square so if he comes
in I can just eliminate it take that
night off the board Bobby Fischer didn't
sleep Bobby Fischer did not sleep Bobby
Fischer was a machine a terminator from
Brooklyn and he probably didn't sleep my
Bobby he's probably like you know he
probably was a bit of a terminator okay
now I can allow this one a sack the
exchange and I'd like sacrificing so he
can go
and go night check would I have to give
up the exchange and that seems like one
of the more interesting positions we get
so he's going for it good Tate with a
pawn and this position is quite
interesting because I'm aiming to play
Bishop a free now the reason I did not
play Bishop a free last move is that you
could go Bishop c5 so I can go Bishop a
free now and then Queen takes here's a
bit annoying so my other idea is to take
on this one and try to get my knight to
this beautiful square this is a really
this is a this is a really close game
this could go either way this is one of
them this is certainly one of the closer
you know do my poets playing very well
is what I'm gonna say this could go
either way I'm down on time and down on
time and my opponent might now do this
but he cut if he if he did okay well now
I can get my move in Bishop a free so
now I'm happy this is my idea all along
and you saw me play this if you recall
earlier on the French defense and now
I'm just gonna be a pawn up so I'm quite
happy I'm quite happy I'm gonna be a
pawn up I have an open C file to attack
on and of course in the ending you want
to move usual Kings so I'm just gonna
try to get my king sort of centralize
their centralized I don't know why I
said their chess Society do you say in
English free results for a game I yeah
we do I mean I guess we say we're
playing for a free results actually
struggled say the word free sometimes I
don't know why it's a bit one of my
weird where ginger isms 3-3 okay
free can I say it free yeah there are
free results but now I wouldn't say free
results because I'm pulling up an ending
so I should be I should be quite okay so
he's trying to break that's a good idea
and my main idea will be I think when
you have a poor majority what I mean by
poor majority is look where you have
more pawns in your opponent I have free
pawns
he has two pawns
when you have a poor majority in the
ending use your pawns in with the idea
of trying to create a passport and what
I mean by a passport is a pawn where it
doesn't have any obstructions because of
course then you can try to Queen that
pawn but my opponent is playing this
ending very well he's playing very
quickly so that last move of his though
maybe he played a little bit too quickly
but we see okay now I think I'm doing
very well here because when your
opponent has a passed pawn so you can
see this is a passport where is the best
place for your rook the best place is
behind the past pawn so that's a great
way of trying to stop that pawn for
running down the boar so in a rook
ending get your rook behind the passport
would I like to write a chess method
book Wow I mean to be honest lightly
chess books are very hard to write and
you don't you get paid very badly for
writing chess but so it used to be that
way it used to be the case that you'd
get paid awfully I mean I got paid I
worked out I've written you know I've
written a number of chess books in my
life and I worked out that the amount I
was getting worked out probably like
four four pounds an hour something like
that for you know that includes after
royalties which were nothing really you
don't
royalty payments are really quite
shockingly bad and I thought well I
could have work down a super market for
this money and I would have got more
money so you know and because a lot of
publishers are kind of like I'm not
going to say thieves but I'm gonna say
thieves you know they don't they don't
and I could lose on time hick and I've
been more careful they don't they don't
pay fairly you know and they give you
very little royalties while they take a
line share one thing I've always wanted
to do with a company I do ginger GM is
like pay as failures we can afford
because you know it's better I mean
nowadays I mean I just prefer doing DVDs
I'm gonna lose on time I like
okay I'm not losing time I won't lose
some time TV DVDs I prefer doing it's my
preferred way of learning and there we
go I I had enough time to win that one
that was quite close that one so I
prefer doing DVDs I prefer the visual
thing I think I can t um I'm a better
teacher personally doing DVDs and
writing I'm not I don't think I'm a
great writer you know is what I'd say
that was that was very M knows very
tough game which Jeanne you're obviously
a very good play and I would say you're
all underrated at your rating they're so
tough tough game chess Jeanne feels bad
well you play you shouldn't feel bad you
play very well Giggy yo is saying you
bought one of my things you can check
out what I've done of my shop ginger gem
calm I've got loads of stuff in my shop
if you want to buy something ranging
from quite cheap to you know a hundred
pounds for very intensive courses if you
want to if you wanted sort of you know
learn DVD publishing pays better
well I mean it pays okay DVD publishing
me not great I mean it's okay
pens have you sell your DVDs or not you
know so I don't know I mean it's alright
and I prefer doing it I miss it maybe
pays a little bit better okay so who's
up next
so we do have let me just have a look at
the list prior oh all my words now this
is gonna be a tough one prior role ook
and are you still there are you us a
prior of Luke Luke is next in Prior row
and I played last Sunday because prior
wrote is a subscriber to my twitch
channel and pry ro beat me so this game
I'm going to takes it I'm not gonna play
there's not not gonna be any air what
opening this was I can what other but
how could I forget about the parrot
already there's going to be no parrots
in this one not against prior I'm not
saying the parrot could be slightly
dodgy but I'm gonna I'm going to take
prior rose seriously as I can
this pyro Luke is a friend of Spenny of
me oh okay I didn't realize that so you
know spit you know Spenny do you I
didn't realize that pry ro lately is
telling me Spenny it's David Spence
extraordinaire say hello prior I don't
think we've ever met in real life every
prior right I'm not sure I met prior in
magaluf all right so well there you go
when when you were when you're out
partying a Lee Lee how are you feeling
today by the way leakers I'll tell you
what I've had a bit of a about a bit of
a rough day today I mean it's been you
know sort of I was being a bit tired
today for shall we say the it's your
fault Lee it's your fault okay right so
this is a gambit line which I often play
and my pawn on e5 is one of the reasons
I do this gambit line because I can
often try to get this Knight into the d6
square and my opponent is playing theory
and having a pawn on e5 is very good
when you're trying to build up an
attacking position now this is slightly
unusual this move the main move I think
is Bishop here so I'm gonna see what my
opponents idea is and I'm gonna set his
porn because I get my sacrifice porn
back now maybe his idea is Queen takes
it Queen takes it at night see to check
and then when I move my King his Knight
takes this so I should probably over
defend this pawn so the way I'm going to
do that is by moving my Bishop to e3
just to stop him playing Queen takes d4
and if I can get two more moves in like
Bishop c4 or Bishop e2 then castle I'll
be very happy I think I will have a
fantastic position so I'm gonna go
Bishop b2 because it's a little bit more
secure there and I'm just gonna get
castled because I have this pawn on e5
and as I as I keep mentioning I think
having this pawn on e5 gives me a great
basis to start an attack and another
common theme in these positions
is what I'm about to do get the Queen
over to g4 because I start applying
pressure to my opponents King site
[Music]
magaluf I remember going to Magaluf once
Lee I went to magaluf when I was a lot
younger on my own nearly 40 now 39 Jesus
whether were years ago the rippers also
saying when's the Raven DVD coming out
stay tuned
I think the parrots gonna come first
isn't it then the Raven but I remember
going to magaluf and it was just a crazy
place I didn't I didn't I've really
enjoy it that much there was all these
weird games going on in bars where
people in the middle of a bar putting
toilet rolling their bottoms of setting
it online I was like what the hell is
this like jungle of insanity and I was
like man this is like this is a bit too
much human food even for me so I wasn't
you know I think I Magaluf so no it's
ruined by English people I think you
know to be honest
poor old Spaniards who lived there
they're probably like they're probably
like bloody English now come over to our
South they ruin it and you're probably
one of them leave you can probably one
of those scumbags are you joking I'm
joking
don't don't don't just calm down calm
down okay so I've equal importance and I
wasn't sure what I was doing so I just
fight I put my rook on it slightly more
active Square and now let's go hear
something in my eye for some reason her
and how I mean I want to really attack
the King but if I go f4 he goes g6 spots
me over there
so I'm tryna I try to work out working
hard to do this now um I mean Queenie
Disick is Queen e2 just very strong now
it's his night is his night tracked and
I could try to go trip takes here as he
put his knight in a bad position let's
find out so I'm gonna go Queen e2 and
I'm just gonna try to eliminate this
Knight this might be very good
and did it today okay so right so we are
so yeah I think I think might I think
prior rows probably put his night into a
bit of a suspect position there by
putting his night into D free that that
this may be a bit of a mistake of price
that night is a little bit funny and you
can see he's got a little problem over
here because the rook can't get into the
game at the moment and no interaction
we've chats as I've been looking at the
chat for the last two hours and forty
minutes and answering and asking most
questions
but apart from that I agree with your
point
crafty Raph you you are spot on with
your observations thank you for being so
smart okay right so I think we will
continue here with I'm just going to
take this one off the board get rid of
the rook and we well having two pieces
for the rook is generally a very good
thing to do and my position is looking
pretty fantastic now now if I could get
this Knight to this square then I could
sit a knight on here I don't want to
move my knight in straight away cuz it
take it so I'm gonna go on a little
journey and this night is gonna hop over
to see for now so that I can hop in to
ask where do you think Bobby Fischer's
game would be able to keep up in today's
chess world and against the top pros
well um I don't really know what the
question is a hundred percent there I
mean do you mean his game or if he
played at this exactly the same standard
now and exactly the same openings
he'd probably find himself in a little
bit of trouble for the main reason that
you know openings are so important but I
mean Bobby Fischer was a natural chess
player and he was hard worker so if
Bobby Fischer was around today I'm sure
that Bobby Fischer would would be one of
the best players in the world but he
would use compute
he would he would he would he would have
to update his openings his openings were
get in trouble you know at top level
because he didn't work with computers
he'd have to work with computers to to
to cope with good players nowadays so I
think I think you'd have to do a little
bit of work basically Bobby personally I
mean the playing strength of competitors
nowadays is so much higher than it's
ever been in the history of chess this
is one thing that people kind of forget
you know it really really is the chest
that's played nowadays is such a great
level that it's heart you know old
players I mean I think if you look at a
lot of the old players let they just
their level if you look at their games
and just no no we're good enough
compared to what it is you know now so
that's quite as that I think I kind of
answered you there didn't I ha half
answered you yet I think I think I don't
look at okay well it's always good to
look at the best moves isn't it
something I I sometimes struggle with so
can I go here now let's just try it
let's try to finish our prior off shall
we so f6
and prior oh you are in a little bit of
trouble I feel sir a little bit of
trouble and now let's sync that one in
it's a sinker and we're actually
fretting checkmate here you could
probably remember this pattern you're
wrong and that's is checkmate so tough
luck prior oh you put up a damn good
flight there sir but I think the opening
went wrong we've had that opening before
haven't we as well del pre is saying
Simon I nearly purchased your killer DVD
book today
well Neddy's just not good enough is it
say tell me when you did and then I'll
give you a bit of respect and a
shout-out don't nearly me by it by
anything I've got because it's excellent
you'll get you'll put on 400 points just
by looking at the cover of any of my
chess books by looking at the cover
you're instantly
become a better player guaranteed okay
so I'm just so look at the chat ginger
do you know why so many of the great
players of the world in 21 did not show
up to play in Hastings no idea cramp
no idea at all my chess history is not
fantastic it's not too bad either but
it's not great Simon I nearly thought
about considering buying one of your
books today well okay jump on the
bandwagon there sir guaranteed on our
money back of course not
well actually if you buy from ginger GM
we do guarantee any of our DVDs you buy
from ginger Jim if you don't like it you
get your money back that is a guarantee
yes but my books
I'm not anything's doing me really I've
just written them they're done by other
publishers so DVDs yes you do get
guarantee actually but I'm not going to
guarantee you improved just by looking
the cover of my DVDs I'm just wondering
what does a Grand Master actually mean
do you get paid for being this good or
well Grammy grandmas has won the highest
you can become in chess a set for world
champion it's like the high level it
sounds pretty cool as well doesn't it
it's like you mr. Miyagi from CROI
aquila saying and do you get paid well
you do get paid sometimes you get paid
to plan competitions pay for coaching
play for DVDs everything we discuss
really okay now next up is make Hell
towel so let's take you on make Hell
towel if you're still here I can't see
you on the list though make hell so
we're gonna miss you out I also can't
see so we're gonna go to a on Apollo and
a on Apollo let's get it on let's get it
on sir let's get it on and we've only
got a couple of games to go so hello
hello a on are you there sir okay so
what are we gonna play we've played
nearly every opening I think we're now
gonna play the scared Knight variation
so do you know what the scared Knight
variation is
make me towel I can you weren't on the
list I couldn't see on the list I'll
play you next time
put your challenge in I'll play you next
time I'll play you next time in the next
game we're plate calm the hell down
ginger gym fan hello to you sir
well that's very good nickname you got
so you're doing well there you're doing
there it doesn't matter how strong you
are evoke a you're playing me even if
you're a complete beginner doesn't
matter just enjoy it you know enjoy the
opportunity to play ground monster maybe
you learn something maybe you won't just
enjoy it
yes if you could resend the chance I
couldn't see you make me tell in in the
chat I might miss you okay so if he went
there I was gonna I was gonna move my
knight back to g8 hence the scared
Knight variation but this is a typical
response in the center of the board okay
to see your challenge now so you have
put your challenge back in is a d5 here
we come
and I can see your change now you'll get
a game after this and I'm now gonna try
to take over the center a bit quite
weird we've got like a reverse
friendship and we are well my plan is
probably just the develop very quickly I
might try to get an attack against f2
but let's bring my Knights out in a very
sensible manner Knights defending the
center of the board and I just need to
get my bishop out and get my king castle
and everything will be rosy ah look at
this my opponent is joining in the fun I
mean this is quite a pretty position
isn't it okay well I'm gonna be the
first to take something so I've gained a
tempo and Jesper has made the very
intellectual chat saying chess is more
fun than cheese well it depends doesn't
it Jasper it depends on the cheese it
depends on the chess it depends how you
play your chess and how you eat your
cheese
a good fondue can you be a good fondue
can you be a good fondue date that you
know I like a good fondue don't we all
like a good fondue ok so right well I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna keep it simple
this game we're just gonna we're gonna
try and whip off the Queen so there they
go and around this little guy up here
with the idea of maybe bringing this one
out as well something like that my
opponents playing well specially for the
rating I mean you're only your rating is
906 is that even a real number is 906 a
real number and chess can you actually
I'm not being too rude I might put 906
is that's pretty if I lose to a 906 I'll
be the laughingstock so just you know
but that that is a 906 Wow you play very
well for a 906 you're certainly a lot
better lap so sorry I didn't mean to
like just completely rip you apart there
with your your rating I already want to
mildly rip you apart no I'm joking
it's getting late okay right so let's
bring my opponents playing well he's
even wants to go here and take this porn
so okay I'm just gonna develop he can
have a porn if you want to do you can
have it forth so I think I've got I've
dropped one draw against the parrot
opening today and every other game has
been a win and I think we've got two
games to come after this one
and what's going on with my eye you can
see I'm just gradually fading away here
my eye is now dropping off as well by
the way if you like today's show and you
want to get chance to play me I'm
streaming tomorrow my twitch channel
ginger GM so you can come over there and
I'm going to be playing again there and
we're gonna have some prizes tomorrow if
you do manage to get a result against me
you win a DVD so if you
today's show try to catch me tomorrow on
my channel okay so my poets found the
right move forking me and I'm gonna
bring my rook in now and I have a nice
idea of castling
getting my route to h8 and going plunk
down there on that square something like
that at what hour and my streaming I
don't even know what I advertised if you
go to my facebook page I have a quick
look now and I can't because I'm
actually playing and you guys will see
it and go to ginger GM Facebook it'll be
there con even more time I post it can't
even remember something o'clock there
you go something o'clock so so okay so
I'm going to continue with my plan the
other plan I had was trying to move my
bishop around this way which also mate
maybe it was even stronger there at the
moment I'm just gonna drop back so I
don't lose it and my bishop stops his
knight coming to any of these squares
cuz I take it off and I still have my
simple plan just bring my rook to h8 and
playing like that on mid date oh yes it
midday tomorrow
okay so twelve o'clock so it's a lot
earlier than today I'm starting eight
hours earlier then today so I might see
you guys around there hello Charlie
you going downstairs Charlie um so
Charlie's my charlie is the chess code
you can also check out Charlie Charlie
the chess cat as well Charlie the chess
cap put Charlie on camera or riots well
I I do agree I do agree with your
sentiment there but unfortunately
Charlie being a cat doesn't always like
you know showing his face and he's
popped downstairs probably to eat I'd
love to put on the camera we even had
the Charlie if you if you here at the
start of the show Charlie the cat was
was here he was here he was he was
enjoying himself right so which way do I
go do we come this way or do we come
this way so many so many tempters let's
go this way and try to come in to one of
these two squares over here
that of what I've got my eye eye ball no
it's bit of a it gets bit difficult when
you can't see in you're playing chess
you know this is kind of one of those
near necessities okay well my ponent
played much higher than its rating but
his position is start to starting to
smell and I have quite a nice checkmate
here and that one is another double
checkmate and you can see the king is in
two chicks and it can't survive so thank
you for the game a on a polo you play
much higher than your rating well done
good game good game what about blind
focus well way things are going prior I
might have to go blindfold tres at the
moment so who have you got next we got
make hell towel okay so come on make how
are you gonna be the man who beats me
you know what we might have to do we
might have to go for this one do you go
you know if you've been here for the
whole show we're gonna have to get we're
gonna have to give it another go guys if
we can if he goes ecigs I can't play
exits scholars mate if I lost in two
moves it would be pretty embarrassing so
are we gonna see the parrots my opponent
is thinking he's already terrified of
the parrots bark in its beak barking its
beak
he's gone f6 allowing the parrots here
comes the parrots oh I think him I think
he meant to play a fight because in the
chat he's gone
oops okay what is this the parrot
strikes again sorry for delay that's
okay that's okay make make hell tau not
a problem not a problem I'd love to get
a piece here because that'll be
checkmate can we try to do that without
me going blind okay let's go for what is
going on I bought this one let's let's
let's try to get the the big thing can
we get three out of three with the
parrot that would be awesome three out
of three with the parrot can we do that
is the parrot goodbye Simon's eye if it
was like that was going on I think
somehow something sneaked into my
eyeball okay so now I find it's trying
to get it you know I might blindfold
chesses incoming the way it's going but
he wants to try to play this one new
opening day it certainly is isn't it
make today today is weird
opening hour so let's take that one can
we do that I've got to watch out for
this check watch out for the check
Williams don't okay what about this this
looks like the most interesting way to
play if he checks me we know how the
parent works we calmly move the King the
parrots proper so yes it's a bit
annoying when you're playing chess and
you're going blind in an eye it's not
recommended I would say and it does seem
like I know what the hell's going on why
but anyway I'm a fighter so we will
continue now how do I like it
I'm not a great fan at the moment of my
position especially if he gets something
like here
checkmate coming in that would be pretty
awful but the parrot is very resilient
animal so we will try and just develop
normally
sorry about this so my only move really
where I can come back again but I don't
want to swap Queens even though I
probably should be swapping Queens so
I'm just gonna move the bishop here and
try to attack him with my knight so
could this be the first and only game I
lose today could it be well I hope not
because the parrot needs to keep its
record and now look I've got my little
pieces wrap in a little in the little
position there don't scratch not give
you know I've got something in my eye
dives very annoying I have to say when
you've got things stuck in your eye say
but not much I can do about that now
and we're gonna go maybe for rook F one
day something like this which I do that
jeez the reason I the reason rope
rubbing it cuz I'm trying to get it out
whatever it is okay so my opponent now
threatening to check on any three so I'm
just gonna give myself this square for
my king get the King to this one I will
go and get the I wash out this is one of
the this is one of the comments I get
the most by heart attack chess and again
it's weird how a lot of people you know
when they watching streamers they they
notice the appearance more than anything
else and I've noticed there's a lot from
streamers you know not here but
elsewhere they're like oh look at that
look at that and they're not actually
looking at what the streaming but this
is why I get a lot I don't watch the
people so perplexed by the color of my
beard and the color of my hair and they
say his PhD ginger but his hair is not
ginger mmm what is going on why am I so
confused this is I get this a lot and
it's like when my hair is ginger but
obviously it's saying through the light
and also I get them put more wax on my
hair in general so it's not gonna be as
ginger but it's it's just I just wait
very peculiar when people sort of come
why is his hair this color and they they
seem to like you know people seem to
just get very confused very confused why
am i confused why is it yeah it's a I
don't hope if you lose will start crying
which should remove anything okay that's
not a bad idea
aerosol if I lose I might start crying
and that is a good solution of my eye I
like the way you're thinking
my opponent melt make hell towel is
saying still in theory completely
correct mr. Tao we're still it was still
in the opening books mate we're still in
the opening books don't talk about his
hair you pillock
well okay Thank You ginger I'm right
although again these my poem is playing
well but he's a bit down on time I'm
hoping my King and this is what normally
happens in the para your King starts on
the Kings side but it slowly
wriggles it way around to safety on the
Queen side so that is what we're gonna
try and do I'm gonna try to get my king
to be free and hopefully it will sit
there reasonably comfortably and
but my parents playing very very
sensible and he has got extra material
and now he wants to be a bishop here to
stop that one so okay let's go there
because now my knight might be able to
move which she couldn't do before
because of the pin it's a standard
parrot you son the up Mary this is just
a standard parrot this is your everyday
parrot position and I was gonna say
rubbish but no we're not gonna let you
down parrot okay now I don't want to
exchange Queens because it's just not on
the Efus of the parrot but I don't know
what else they did because if I go rook
here
will he take they're quite probably and
maybe I should start chasing his Queen
but then he goes Queen there and that's
also quite annoying so I just try to
work out how to deal with this position
and I can't
I might have to exchange Queens but then
he's gonna take here okay so maybe
Knight G phrase I need to defend e4 is
that is that a way to proceed let's try
that one at the moment
Knight to G free and play like that okay
I was a bit worried about him taking
that but I was hoping he wouldn't do X Y
and done it thus you know so far and he
is now two pawns to the good so I need
to start flinging my bits in there but
I'm up on time I'm up on time so I've
got two bishops remember I don't
actually think much about having two
bishops but people say two bishops is
amazing so I'll take their word for it
and he's trying to Queen that's that's
that's that's not that's not very nice
of you is it still try to Queen your
pawns dare you okay let's put the King
here because that's where I wanted to
put that guy and now I need to get rid
of that Bishop because he was
controlling that Square and control it I
will as much as I can by putting a
bishop on e3 what and right
next step my opponent is doing very well
he has the better position he's a so far
outplay me I'd say but his time is short
and there's only one more game to go
after this one but that is that mistake
have I caught my opponent out with this
move which is attacking his knight in
attacking his Queen as I'm going blind
at and blind and what is going on did I
miss that one I wanted to say no but
I've suddenly the blindness is hitting
me yes I just missed that one he's got
Queen here chick oh dear this is not
going well I'm gonna have to hustle now
I'm gonna have to hustle especially if
he checks me here okay you didn't check
me there that's good
I've got a little bit of a rest bite but
not much okay I'm gonna have to play
dirty I'm gonna have to try win on time
I've totally some reason I totally
forgot that my opponent was greening
okay so he's gonna try to take
everything okay last desperate attack
could this be my defeat of the day this
should be free come on Ari you're my
only porn you're my only chance go boy
go boy go go Harry go go go go oh I've
got him I've got him my opponent has
fallen into a checkmate position and
this is a well known checkmate I'm a
little bit lucky we might even show the
power to two bishops there woof that was
tough
that was tough you play very well a
towel there very good game and now the
last game we're gonna play before the
show is over and well I think we're
gonna call it a day now because my eye
is killing old chess Society
I did say I'll play you so let's get a
game on but make this the last game and
then after this we're gonna take the
stream down and I'm gonna wash my eye
out
before I lose an eyeball okay so chess
society the last game chess society
I think the bunch of people from Italy
who also stream so go and check them out
and this is gonna be the lost last game
of the stream and I hope you enjoyed it
and remember do check out my channel
ginger GM if you want to see more of me
if you had enough of me I understand a
lot of people get that as well you know
I don't blame me I don't blame you if
you had enough it's okay
it's understandable right um but it's
been a fun stream and thank you so many
of you for tuning in to it I've enjoyed
it it's been fun with more so the most
important thing is we've got three out
of three with a parrot off forgot that
last game free now to free with a new
opening that we invented today new
opening so it's good stuff um right now
try and look at the questions but
unfortunately the monitor with the chat
is that side and as I can currently not
see out of that eye it's making it a
little bit tricky a little bit demanding
the eyeball gambit the carrot is strong
in you Simon isn't D doesn't their
parents that the parents dummy good
Simon is counted an eyeball for the
stream well you know it's worth it just
to just to be here with you guys it's
worth an eyeball you know give an
eyeball up for you guys any day of the
week and the colors in the back might be
affecting you possibly and scare okay
the dumbest opening a chest fury but
parody it works I kind of go along with
that as well I mean it does look silly
but it's got a bit of bite the parrot it
has a bit of boy I will have an eye
patch and a parrot on my shoulder I'd
like that Vijay is saying here my next
stream I will literally turn into a pyro
I mean that would be good if I is going
and also I might do that might actually
have an eye patch and a parrot that I
like that that's good comment nicely a
nicely yeah maybe tomorrow I will be
who's that sucker with a parrot on his
shoulder that is the ginger GM or
otherwise known as the Pirates the
Pirates streamer red beard eyepatch
parrots who knows and okay well I'm
going to get my Bishop here because
we've seen this kind of idea before
trying to stop my opponent costly and
now let's see if I can open up this file
now Queen here looks kind of good I
could also let's just play this first
because my rook is very good on this
line as well and I'll play it very
natural moose so we're castle and try to
get a queen out over here I think where
we can pressurize some of these guys so
let's go here because we're pressurizing
c2 and I'm also threatening Bishop takes
here and then Queen takes d4 so we do
that one we will do that one as well
and this looks like a good position of
me and I've quite a lot of frets and now
I can take this one so I'm picking up a
cheeky little porn there a cheeky little
porn and I like my parents keeping the
Queen's I'm probably good probably a
wise decision but I'm going to well kind
of pin that one so if the knight moves
I'll take the Queen's off with a very
nice ending and I'm getting ready to
launch that baby into his position
rook c2 incoming how how do I do this
how did I get something in my eye
drawing a string and then you want to
answer that how did something magically
during the course of a stream end up in
my eyeball does anyone know the answer
to that because I don't know how I
managed to do that and it's really
annoying me at the moment
okay I'm going greedy I'm gonna take all
his pawns now let's get them all off and
is it an angry symbol tomorrow well I
don't know if the prior right--don't one
can do tomorrow I'm thinking I might
tomorrow
do some subscriber blitz like we've done
here did I eat chili and touch it no I'm
eating chili today I am we had a kebab
earlier we ordered a kebab yeah I do
like a bit of a kebab doesn't anyone
like a bit of a combat so it can't be
that I think about but you did have
chili in it but it's not that so I
literally I can feel it in my eye you
know you feel something there not a very
nice feeling I don't recommend anyone
goes for it but anyway I'm sure it'd be
alright it's only it's Annie and I after
all sorry and I surely a tie and yeah so
I'll try to get one more bloody thing
and I don't know what the next chest
comm thing is going on you should check
out this their own schedule see what
they got planned this game seems to be
going to right so it looks like we've
only drawn one game today and of course
the only draw I had was in the parrot
opening and as we discussed I've got a
lot of ports a lot of pawns going on and
I should have too many porns it should I
know do I have something flash here like
rook here trying to eliminate more
pieces because when your pieces up or
when your material up but I've got one
two three more pawns it's a good idea to
swap pieces off the board making it
simpler to go as we go a lot and don't
leave after the stream because I'm gonna
we're gonna give everyone a raid and
we're gonna go to BIC first Channel and
give him so he's a great streamer lovely
guy you guys can check him out
[Music]
I'm just trying to remember the raid
command to do it okay so and let's think
about grabbing another one but that
would not be a good idea now I fit who
said if you got a passport it must be
pushed so that is a passport so we will
push that one down the board and try to
get a queen okay now I could grab should
we be greedy let's just take everything
I'm going to take every single porn
every single porn is coming off the
border and he must have a problem with
his back rank now so his king has to
come up his king is looking very exposed
so let's try to attack it and can we
keep the attack going another check here
how about this where does he move his
king now does he have to come further
forwards that would be pretty brave of
him because then I have rookie for
coming in coming in into the position
and this is looking pretty good so it's
I hope you enjoyed if you've got a
chance to play him if you didn't get
chance play me hopefully you will in the
future and I'm pretty sure there's no
back rank I've just got to watch out for
this and after this move I think my
opponent is well he's really losing now
mean he's losing I'm just gonna move
this oh my King can't get back ranked
and it's all over so there we go
so thank you everyone who's joining the
stream today if you want to see more of
me then go check out my twitch channel
ginger GM and I'm now gonna douse my eye
and find out what the hell's going on
but I it's been raining doable three
hours so thank you everyone who's tuned
in to this watching some cool chests and
parrot variations and watching my I in
slow decline so it's quite late here and
getting its after 11 o'clock in the
night so I'm gonna go and have a rest
and leave you two I hope you will have a
good rest of the weekend enjoy your
Sunday tomorrow and again thank you so
much so goodbye for now right and I'll
see you all later